[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we back taxis live
back
boston was nice but we back
new name what's going on shannon c hayes
you said let's talk about hi yeah y'all
ready to talk silly i already see what
y'all doing hustling motivate what's
going on the levels the levels do be
general mac my man your salute to
general mac he be rapping
yo he comes through i see him outside
wrapping around rubbing lord salute to
you brother you don't have to do it but
what i see it gives me motivation you
know what i'm saying to do we doing oh
here go my mains black conflict x what's
going on that's a very strong name yeah
you already know what it is
lydia ambassador ham solo here on the
road six hour drive midwest gaming
convention
all right all right you know what i'm
saying necromancy akw gear knicks the
donald tackles salute we good on the
levels no doubt mike's a nice addict
talk to the people
can you guys hear me fine
sounding good on my side
well i i have my mic like in a new place
now no doubt the sith lord the lords are
back yeah we back we back we back you
know what i'm saying so hopefully we get
solved for a whole episode but he's
still in transitional movement so we'll
see because damn it we need help with
these
they're killing us they kill they like
you and attic yeah listen i'm like all
right they keep killing us all they want
everyone wants to come here
they're going crazy so look oh my god
leon victor you know where the powder oh
the powder is up baby advanced gg.com
right now i'm rocking
the split gate rocket pop that joint is
fire if you know about bomb pop pops for
back in the day the red white and um
blue kind of ice cream joints
that's how it tastes it's really good i
think this is the i feel like this is
the strongest formula this is the one
that yeah we pushing peanuts you know
what it is 10 off cold iron lord
advanced gg was promoted you already
know what it is um but yeah i definitely
rocked it also if you guys we got a new
joint if a lot of you don't like
caffeine caffeine don't want any of that
extra stuff
you just want something with vitamins
and electrolytes with no
caffeine
just um go to the site now we got a new
line it's called hydration and that's
like kind of like a gatorade but no
sugar and it's really good so go check
that out you can use cold iron lord on
that so go check that out akw he's on
the season gaming podcast oh yeah
solvents all yeah he made a cameo
because i think on
aim's episode 200 shout out to the big
cast i pulled up for a hot minute let's
see what was going on but um yeah it's
going to be a good show we started to
stay for the whole joint king will be
pulling up holding early
maybe some little
cameos we'll see how we go but i miss
y'all man eduardo williams y'all have
any zoom links what you mean what's zoom
length
[Music]
you're trying to get on the show
let me know what's good y'all moving
that powder baby powder necklace here
let's go ahead
look it's a good product man positive
powder you already know it is but look
we are going to
chill we get everybody in the realm we
got some spicy topics to talk about
and uh yeah we'll see you in a bit
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target
um
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making
[Music]
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
check my
[Music]
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled feeling to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tiller uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vote follow on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled put on the b.o dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boil you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be keeping these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
who
let's do it daddy cheater mosey going
down over to the website go check it out
whether you're gonna get that focus for
them gaming session that energy a little
perk for the gym we want to get some
swag some merch maybe an ice shaker go
right on over there check out the
products but again really cool products
they don't hide behind any type of
proprietary blend raw nonsense it's all
transparent as far as the ingredients
the label green tea caffeine kind of a
healthy form of natural caffeine none of
that crash none of that stuff so yeah
again go check it out you run in there
you add it to your cart use that
referral link that we got in the
description and then you make sure on
the checkout you're putting in iron lord
again iron lord on the checkout get
yourself a nice discount when you're
checking out advanced gg and like i said
try the product for yourself see what
you think about it the lords we love it
and we are powered by vsg so check that
thing out
[Music]
is
[Music]
if i can imagine this cooler give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that you can't never
still be the king of the statues since
the juvenile i've been cursed with a
curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it in
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
levels talk real quick let's make sure
we got some love yeah there we go
hello hello this is the dude you guys
hear me fine yeah
we're good we're good i have my mic
right here now now you see here it's
right there it's peeking from the corner
it's right here to the left my mic
you're like my mic is over there
bothering me
[Music]
and we
are live welcome to the iron lords
podcast llc and also the lords of
gaming.net episode number 255. there's
another glorious sunday we're back at
the round table on the lord's day
and today we've got xbox and bethesda
showcase announcement
ps5 game trials and ps plus stacking
w
wv game rumors and ps5 vrr to discuss so
we're gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the once again reunited
four horsemen of gaming the original
gaming knights of the realm here at the
round table oh we reunited i'm gonna
take a week off i'll talk to you guys
right now you're gonna mess it up you're
gonna break the group up
my co-host with the cold mouse my
brother another mother the difficult
game conqueror lord of his own world and
the how of the young wolf my man lord
attic fresh back from pax east how are
we doing sir
doing pretty good uh first thing i want
to say is uh thanks for all the uh the
support that we got from uh our
adventures at pax uh you know what
what's funny is is you you don't know
how bougie these people are to you
eating with them because
like they they they were disgusted
what was
totally messed up my meal going on now
they destroyed king's men what happened
i had what was it a shrimp fungal
and they
didn't put shrimp inside
so so when you have a mofongo right yes
yes the the base mofongo usually comes
with pork crackling in it right okay now
they have variations of that the
variations depending on the type of meat
that you put in the mofongo should not
have pork cracklin it should have that
that that meat right so
king asked for a a a what what they call
a fungal yeah but it had yucatan
cassava it had cassava have plantain and
it's supposed to have shrimp and that's
it
they went ahead put the shrimp aside
right gave them the shrimp like five of
them yeah fire little baby shrimp
and then they went ahead and would
support crackling in the in the in the
formula
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's funny is like because i i don't
really eat any type of foods like that
like i'm about the fast food place or i
made food yeah so like we're we're in
the uber going back it's all said that
he's like showing me this and like dude
i can't read half of that i don't know
what
it
is
it was
but the thing is i don't know what any
of it is right so i'm sitting there and
and he's like okay do you like chicken
i'm like chicken
what's funny is i'm the one that got the
basic stuff yeah and i was the only one
happy yo he was the only one everyone's
low-key disgusted with sorry boston
spanish food and we sit there and like
sauce like yo this is that [ __ ] guys
no no and the funny thing is you're the
only one like my meal is good
he got what he got chicken in front but
you got chicken and french fries he's
like hey mess this up
no doubt what you've been playing man
what else we're going to do
i don't know if i'm allowed to say what
game i'm playing so i'm not going oh
yeah that's right that is right you are
playing a lot of games
yeah they will be a review i think the
10th
is when the embarrassment yeah yeah the
10th yeah somewhere around there yeah
you ain't supposed to be yeah yeah good
good catch good catch i i i don't i
don't know what what day it is exactly
because uh usually i read that when i
start to
my my coverage like i said look when it
comes to reviews i know i'm not supposed
to stream it i don't know that's
supposed to leak anything so it's like
the logistics can come after i beat the
game yes agreed agreed no doubt that's
been it sir
yeah it's uh you know that i mean we
went to pax uh i i've been playing a lot
of minecraft like a ridiculous amount of
money
i've seen doing that so you're getting
your minecraft on no doubt yeah the game
is just a completely different game than
usual i mean it's still minecraft
and i'm talking to him in chat
he goes i'm coming right now king hold
on one second right i'm playing elder
run right he said i can't find my
diamond pickaxe he said now i know damn
well i put my diamond pickaxe someplace
here what are you talking about
i just made this diamond pickaxe and i
can't find it he said hold on one second
so he saw his girlfriend's little avatar
over there he killed her
in her pocket
it was like oh yeah here it is yo
chill chill
what
no here's the thing like we was in a a
position in the mountains this is why i
killed my girl
here's the thing
there's the the explosion is fine though
there's context behind yeah i need this
context
we were sitting there and we were making
like this underground castle thing and i
know that the only person that's been
there is me and her so she's i i think
she was um she was eating or something
she wasn't at her mic
and i'm sitting there i'm like i'm like
do you have the do you have the diamond
pickaxe
no
do you have the diamond pickaxe she's
not saying nothing so i'm saying they're
going through every chest double
checking uh-huh
he's like yo like i need to get this
done i'm like all right and i'm like she
gotta have it
there's no way
so wait wait this gets down a disturbing
path because it's like so basically what
you're saying is if someone lies to you
it could go down like it could go
oh no like
and put it in the chest and say they'll
never find it here
he happy to go to jail he's like she
shouldn't alive i knew she had to pick
out
yo
yo addict's a real one here he about his
business
no doubt
of course we have the most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer lives with a
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the lord of clarity
and lord patron of the iron bank my man
finally back
lord salvador how are we doing sir
i'd be better if i had moved already but
i haven't moved
yeah we thought she was moved already
yes i know i'm living out of boxes the
mountains the boxes behind me had to dig
in the boxes to get the mics back out so
you know you could not miss another week
mm-hmm no i won't be here next week
mother's day i gotta spend time with mom
dude
i'm glad to be back yeah i got to spend
some time with my brothers at paxa you
know
situations weren't ideal but you know
oh we're going to do that oh we all we
are we learn hey
we live where we learn we live
all i have to say
[Laughter]
[Music]
at the bnb you enjoyed your time based
on your bed situation he said at the bnb
because that's exactly what it was b and
b
bs
there wasn't no air in that mattress
shout out to box springs you know what
you know what's funny song
what they they rushed upstairs at the
quickness and got those upstairs
i mean they didn't even look good
this is where this is where like dude
this certain things you just assume okay
it's not even a comfort it's like
when you purchase certain types of beds
certain type of reps require certain
types of accessories yes and if you
don't have those accessories that is not
a bed oh that's not a badge a lot of
false advertisements yes kawasaki going
on yo
[Laughter]
shout out to the western who will be
getting our patronus next year
boston you know look it's just not the
same situation like we would do in la or
another city but the bmbs are a little
more premium situations but uh yeah man
what else we're going to have you got a
chance to play anything we've just been
straight dude nah i've been on the same
damn game of mlb the show for the past
two weeks i haven't been able to like
really sit down and play anything apart
from what i played you know i obviously
got to play a little ninja turtles at
pax east excited
uh evil west is yeah it's it's it's high
on my list for this year don't said rims
sponsored by sony
you know you disrespectfully this
disrespectful you already know i respect
that though no doubt and of course i'm
sorry
real quick though yes big shout out to
our homies over at the bitcast episode
200
just wrapping up i believe yeah yeah
those guys are awesome shout out to
travis shout out to ayn shout out to
hogue and dan everybody over there at
season gaming uh that's a great
accomplishment yeah
i lost track what what number we stopped
yeah we're gonna have to do something
for 300. we don't really do we need to
celebrate our episodes more milestones
more but yeah yeah salute yeah 300 we're
gonna do something we got to do
something 300 is crazy so we never know
we got to try to get that phil spencer
let them know let them know you know
what i'm saying we got a while we got a
little wobble yeah man i salute to um to
the big cavs that was what's up i did
try to pull up for a little bit so
that's pretty solid yeah that's it no
doubt no doubt get the super chat ready
because they they're going yeah i'm copy
pasting don't worry no doubt
they literally really miss you
and
of course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka the access gamer oh
the prophet of xbox so i mean king of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing fantastic um
just did my bed in boston
you just you just got home yeah no you
just got home
yeah i just got home man i'm back you
know stuff is different out here
did a four day stretch
apparently the food's different too
back here man we could get real rose
compo you know
dude you can get rid of rose composure
in the bowl there you go
i want to give a shout out to a couple
of people oh
he in there let me tell you something
that is the definition of pull up
when you're like yo
i'm like we here what's up we're gonna
do it um i don't want to put people
business out there like that so
what i'm saying is he's a real one like
a real one um it was a couple of real
ones that have been needed
that was like yo what's going on king
hey
and you know i'm like yo take a picture
let's go let's do this
and whatever so
that was real dope to see yes um
somebody recognize you or somebody
wanting to even take a picture i have a
conversation with you about something
real quick and um like i said i'm not
you know i'm not standoffish so uh hit
me up so that was real dope um shout out
to shakur stevenson combat talk yes
last night um start off a little rocky
but i got my c legs and i had to control
that that was cognitive
i'm not throwing anyone
it's a team effort
it's it's okay he's okay he was there in
clutch when i needed him yeah
was just outclassed man
he was just
outclassing every scent of the word you
know shakur is definitely
a rising star and he answered
questions nah man that's that's to stop
that i just said i didn't know what they
were gonna say two-pack
all right
two-pack guys
[Laughter]
continue no no it was just um it was
just real something real dope to see uh
the maturation of um
a young man he's he's growing into those
boots and he's he's carrying it with
with a lot of pride he got in the ring
and he uh proposed to his uh fiancee um
well now she's his fiancee uh you know
because he got the checks the checks is
coming in now so now he can pay for the
big wedding and stuff like that and you
know you secure your home base that's
the first thing so it showed that he has
good people in this corner uh level head
and he showed respect to valdez and you
know valdez show respect to him at the
end i mean that camps didn't do that but
again um those individuals did and
that's something dope to see what i've
been playing
um since i get got back i'm playing life
no i'm just joking yeah um
i've been playing l the ring oh you've
been in the bag the clown is a little
upset with you by the way i don't care
like i don't care what y'all say
it's i haven't had my skyrim
that's been a long time maddie said that
right so this is my skyrim all over
again
and the fact of the little minutia to
the game where i can i finally made it
to the farming place everybody makes it
too so i turned around and i saw it i
went absolutely buck bananas i'm
screaming into the mic i have found that
farming place i'ma get paid baby i stood
there for one hour i got 50 million
dollars damn
yeah i was i was out i was outside i was
doing my i was making i was crafting i
was doing things the game
is
there for you to play it how you're
going to play it like um chris showed me
some
gatherer dragon that you don't even have
to
uh see like it's a boss that you don't
even have to go optional giant yes so i
found that he told me go to this place
and lay down on the floor
what it says it has a button that says
lay down okay okay
i lay down my man go put his little arms
across his body like he's dying
and then the world stop and go start
going into reverse and all the
travesties that went on to start and
repair itself but either uh the big a
dragon three-headed dragon from um from
godzilla
is in a like a egg shape in the middle
of the screen i'm like what the hell is
that
it is the dopest cinematic
it yeah i'm just like wow man i'm i'm
loving every little bit of piece of this
game so you guys that want to run out
there and end it and skip past stuff and
don't explore the world i'm getting
every drop of this girl girl girl
[Laughter]
my mind was awful
[Laughter]
no but um definitely um just the same
way i played uh skyrim i'm playing this
game the same way and i'm loving it the
same way and attic is probably right it
didn't be a problem
no doubt no doubt and of course we got
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that realness to
the realm of the iop not telling what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear shout out to everybody that pulled
up boss on us on pax and bug snacks
everybody that pulled up man it was so
cool to see
you know people just be like yo can i
take a picture you know just and then
the devs you know the games just being
back at the convention once again with
the team with the squad well you know we
worked hard people just saw a lot of the
fun part but we were
hard shout out to 108 dragons oh for
sure
you know shout out to technical um
new solutions that we learned uh be more
more effective during our pandemic we
are prepared now we are prepared now we
learned a lot and again what a way we
owe him a lot of credit i guess shout
out to everybody we get good gaming man
like oh that's just squash
just like i said so many cool games we
did a podcast on site um if you if you
haven't seen it it's up on the isla
podcast playlist check that out ton of
stuff there we talk about what's going
on we got tons of content salute evil
west definitely stand out shout out to
plunder panic you know what i'm saying
we have fun with dad dolmen die by the
blade iud chronicles
teenage mutant ninja turtles let us play
four players teenage mutant ninja
turtles we we need to fix that but um
that's just me being a media booster you
know how we do but um yeah look
everybody was good it was good to be
back um
for me again shout out to filing duke
shout out to mr maddie plays who pulled
up mr maddie plays pulled up at fact
salute to him you know saying we also
did an episode about that or ultimate go
check that out that's up on our last
stand and we got the episode now it
should be 3.99 other joint where you
talk about um what's going on and uh mac
and cheese debate it's a big debate in
the community i don't know um
dumbest debate i've ever seen in my life
with your mac and cheese yeah with your
mac and cheese with your mac and cheese
we got to know where you stand because
you might be a menace to society that's
only when you're juvenile you rocking
that's the kid's body thank you that's
the kid's box you got your hand you're
holding it this is they have the whole
spoon like that like i'm gonna eat oh
you don't use the savage with the spoon
because technically that's what that's
the big spoon mama having a plate yeah
you know what i'm saying that if you eat
mama spoon you just greedy you just hate
me
waiting to get to the to the plate so i
need to poke my man
in the corner you know
civilized civilized you know what i'm
saying
that's ridiculous
it's definitely one of those
it's definitely one of those things
right like you could eat that with
anything like
i i know people that like don't make it
in those little containers and they'll
eat it from the cup like oh that's pure
savagery what are you hanging out with
shout out to west virginia
start to look around with who's who
who's in your company
taste the plastic right now
that's like that's the kfc mac and
cheese dude
that they had a little powder yeah water
powder
you're a little loud like you're yeah
yeah he actually louder than normal
that's funny you know he's low just just
a little bit check your arm windows set
it first before you do that but all make
sure you enjoy the 65. um we got that
last word about this i got travis we had
the legend jar venus on and actually
that's when a lot of another debate
happened about ray weapons uh depths
versus cure crafting check that out and
as far as what i've been playing um i
can talk about it even though it's in
beta um lost i idolized i've been
playing that a lot of potential a lot of
potential turn bait kind of gives me
fire emblem and um what's that banner
saga vibes together
fully voice acted great story
and it's just such a mixed bag there's
parts with graphically cinematic and
stuff that looks good and then there's
how to times the frame rate so i'm gonna
give them a lot of feedback i think this
game could really be great i know they
had the kickstarter jumping off i think
it's an xbox preview if you're a part of
that go check that out i'm with sarvo
the mlb the show i've been rocking man
my robot wrong until october march to
october i've been killing that and uh
yeah as far as that then that's the rate
shout out to the team last night shout
out to taz forte back for dead pixels
you know what i'm saying we was you know
uh black iron man black iron man slew we
was rocking that joint you know i'm
saying hold on yo somebody added got a
fan
addict got a fish out of that horrible
oh
hey that's not like a hey addict hey
that sounds like that's lovable what's
going on we need you to read this out
loud yeah attic you're going to read
what aurora wolf had to say to you
that's my babe lord adam
smiley face
that's actually my girlfriend
that there's some some people in the
community
i didn't know you know we go around
addie got a lot of that gun
she could have just gotten any old photo
of you with somebody and just put it
that you know as a avatar
salute to the oral she you know she she
your beard was holding it down he was
very respectful he wasn't he'd even go
to the party that's how i really kept it
he's like nah y'all go i'm i'm handling
business so salute what go on in boston
don't do that don't do that to him he
was good he was good
he cannot either deny or confirm
[Laughter]
got to my phone to light up any seconds
so let's get some super chats man
oh yeah yeah real quick before the super
chats big shout out to our homies over
at sacred symbols episode 200. gotta
give a shout out to another austin and
colin and chris
shout out to micah shout out to my man
ben the team's out there you know dude
it was a sacred symbols event y'all
they're 200 you know what i'm saying
they did it and they did invite us we
just me and you know maddie had packs at
the same time also so it wasn't like we
weren't invited but it was a secret
simple day but it's a last damn media
thing we'll be back the whole team
whatever so for those who are asking on
twitter because i'm gonna get you super
chats we gotta hear the good all right
pronunciations we got raiden blade
member for 15 months thank you sir i
want to point out i could have i could
have said that
for the record
i know how to pronounce that one yes yes
welcome back brothers i'm sorry i have
no respect for ratbag looking forward to
today's y'all know who that is i don't
know what that is i don't know what's
going on
better buy discover your wb and then buy
the splinter cell ip we will see
there we go don otaku five dollar super
chat shout out to [ __ ] for sticking up
for the southern mac and cheese on the
last episode of defining duke i was
definitely ready to roast him here if he
didn't bro i don't encourage that
behavior i had to teach back he don't
even talk about he don't like the
southern joint with the bread like so
you know what i'm saying but like baked
mac and cheese
you could tell he haven't been to the
cookout we got to take him to the to the
cookout to the real one look at him
like i feel i feel like i feel like you
try
[Laughter]
with seasoned food
i'm curious if we look at the top 10
best chefs in the world what what color
are they going to be moving on that's
nice
member for 29 months wow lord go wow
let's get the party started good morning
lords hope all is well playstation is
dead it's wacky just sitting back all
natty in that trash system god bless oh
my god jesus
thank you thank you for the lack of
punctuation i appreciate it yes thank
you
[Music]
is this half a good show got although i
didn't know about this con well i know
what i know about the ketchup on the mac
and cheese oh that's next week that's
the that i told i warn people because
like me and maddie we got a time out
yeah you go there you go that's some new
jersey
it's a different type of movement like
the ketchup with the that's next week i
don't wanna i'm gonna take a l on there
bro you don't do cats by kid you don't
do cat get away from me
nobody ain't doing that
catch up on your eggs that's that's only
if the hash browns okay but what
happened whatever what is a ketchup
mashup is necessary if there's no
seasoning oh see you on that
tip
catsup is great but again if if the
stuff is seasoned properly oh here we go
here we go so no a1 for you either i'm
assuming no no no no i'll hang away just
a little little oh so so so so that's
okay
like you you
[Laughter]
he just wanted a little a little ketchup
on the top
mac and cheese i'm sorry nobody's eating
milk
what have you tried it solved it that's
the question have you tried it yes when
i was five and i didn't like it
i think if i was your server and i'd
have brought you some pristine mac and
cheese you said you'll pass me the
ketchup
no i would have threw the ketchup before
it crossed the ring
remember that conversion could you
please pass the jelly
bean
please pass the poland
for the vegetarian menu they're going to
throw that across the roof
you'll see attic is so so can see he
basic yeah
and yo they have so much dope stuff
there yeah i'd accept i got the mac and
cheese
thank you
i got the mac and cheese put a little
ketchup on here
[Applause]
to be fair yes i have really bad like
digestive issues
i would agree
however i gotta call fraud alone on you
because when you never had five guys for
the first time i warned you about the
kings and fries
i don't care he was like i don't care
i'm gonna do it
hey yo stuff it was acting up afterwards
but you think okay it's worth it that's
surprised though but you saw his face
when
[Laughter]
you
stay away from schools and public places
thank you so much
god stop getting his hands dirty all
right exactly he says all in the name of
the lord
we not promoted that continuing all his
work already
we got playstation coming in hot day one
demos
wow
yo he's stupid
savage good here we go black road to 357
member for 12 months thank you sir
are the iron lords using a live pot
doing a live podcast during the showcase
what do you think of course
we will be reacting to it and the crazy
parts is going to be more like it was
last year because they're doing it on
sunday like they normally do so since
we're not going to e3 because it doesn't
exist we're just we'll be reacting to
the show and then having like a uh like
a show after it mm-hmm
yeah
phil sent me a ticket now i'm in cali
you know yeah it could be
some live elements a lot of people right
out there to seattle with that
mclaren i'm making an announcement attic
is not in california
fair enough what else you got so uh yeah
you're doing live showcase because i'm
here for it xbox because the showcase is
almost dry it's almost dry like pusha t
album a masterpiece in the making
oh
[Laughter]
that's the mac and cheese with the spoon
dudes that's how they moved
continue
there we go italian clown 16 months
remember for 16 months thank you sir
dropping by to say hello all hail the
king glad to see saab on today yes
definitely
then we got blind giant 808 member for
one month thank you sir to say something
man oh we used to say something from
here said king is right 98.
that's what he said that's what he said
yeah that's what he said we're at 98 now
we got the otaku fix five dollar super
chat stopping by the show support thank
you brother appreciate it absolute
we got [ __ ] j remember for ten months
yeah welcome back lords good to see the
gang all together happy sunday and
salute where's jamaican jim ryan by the
way the man's retired yeah
yeah i know we talking about what we
talked about
there we go hollywood rules member for
four months thank you sir
my favorite game coverage on youtube
thank you king excellent job on the
fight last night had to work i had to
work so last night was dope love my iop
sundays great show man
thank you
then we got lucious augustus member for
nine months homie thank you sir
disgraceful
hulk really nba jams dunked on jason
over the past few days it was kind of
some conversation reasonable minds can
differ
exactly always as hogue would say
and we got hardgate cheney
salute to the lords it was great to
catch up with the lords of boston at pax
great time hanging out with you all you
as well my brother yeah brother so real
man so cool to hang out with you to meet
you absolutely girl absolute pleasure
definitely one of our highlights and
great job on the jaffy yes good job on
the
game on daily salute to you yeah yeah
what i'm saying
i got a whole little preview of that sir
and he definitely held up y'all held it
down salute
and we got hollywood rules five dollar
stupid chat shout out to my guys and
king to my end king's jets awesome draft
oh yeah i killed him
yeah i heard that
you know what
he's killing it every year but they be
killing us on the field
i don't care right now
show me some result i just wanted to
play off just one game i feel like i
hear that i hate it
need a doctor strange review from you
guys king been eating like he really did
a bit
of facts coverage
no doubt uh yeah we'll see uh
we got we got doctor strange next week
yeah you know i'm there i know i've been
i've been missing in action a couple
others i got that statue right there
yeah yeah yeah
i'm gonna go watch it too yeah that's
your journey that's one of your favorite
mcu joints for addict let's go and we
got big mad mo remember for 22 months
thank you brother
salute to the lords keep up the great
work been going through some things and
y'all energy helped me get through it so
i appreciate you thank you thank you
brother anything you can do to help no
doubt know what that is
then we got drive by joe oh
yo
joe what are we doing out here what is
we doing
what is safe made it here from last
stand media looking forward to many
podcasts from y'all like chilling with
the boys yes thank you sir
number one
it's in the name watch your mouth
don't drop by joe godzilla black
conflict x
yeah we got sp with the 50 dollar super
chat thing styles p appreciate
can't stay long on the clock right now
i'm just stopping by to show love i have
to give king his flowers for fight night
last night your ability the slow fights
down in real time is amazing had a blast
all love want no doubt
love for the king i like that then we
got platinum jay
elder ring game of the years yeah it
could be a game of the year so it's a
couple of years we needed planted oj in
boston that's what we needed yeah we
need it
then we got drawn tj five dollars which
that morning guys it's morning to you
gotta be a philly dude philly dude was
drawing
dude
jump back to the actual um
to the actual chat yeah i know it's all
over the place i got
alex i'm going slow yeah i got alex yeah
i got clowns clowns is next italian
clowns five dollars super chat ketchup
on eggs is a crime to catch up wow
forget about it wow
that's a goomba coming out
[Music]
appreciate you sleeping on your stomach
with the door open [ __ ] what is going on
what's going on that's a violation
that's a virus
that's a violation
moderators just keep an eye on this
[Laughter]
and forza uh hellblade 2 and fable we
will see you guys
let me say something real quick um
first off
we will be going into that but we're not
going to go too into that because we do
have a prediction an xbox show
uh for those of you who are predicting
that that's new we every year we have a
prediction show on every uh every
platform i know normally we don't do
nintendo but we're going to be doing it
this week we always do nintendo
continue so uh the i think it's the
fifth it's the sunday before the show
will be doing the prediction show where
we'll like really break down the show
yeah but i just want you guys to know
that we will be talking about and
discussing it but we're not like
breaking down that announcement exactly
exactly salute salute what else you got
then we have alexis is uh evolve okay
because alex is about 14 super chat you
guys are cracking me up keep it up you
guys have to do comedy
and we got flame member for 19 months
thank you thank you
sounds like he's here
who wants to join the ilp for the day i
may be able to sneak you on wink wink
hit the bank love you guys also eat your
mac and cheese with the spoon oh hell no
laughs over here
take the water away take the water away
[Laughter]
hard to find remember for 13 months
thank you sir love my guys king i'm
loving the combat talk saab had to take
time off to finalize that only fans
release me
yes
he's in conjunction with manscape
that's a special tear he said shout out
to cog look like luke
looking like luke cage
we got david croissant welcome to lord
bronze put the crust in the chat for
david crusoe oh solve your miz is back
oh here we go my man
let me play with your joystick five
dollar super chat song i'm glad to see
you guys i wish i could have went to
facts to see you
wow look at the icon what's going on why
because he had to have kirby big mouth
mode
i will point out that i i i didn't know
where soft was the whole pack
[Music]
again what is going on
yeah they loose they loose
super
shout out to you sir salute to the
lord's best gaming podcast hands down
proud to be a member here with popcorn
for king's mess oh god
salute to the pitch by the man without
fear i mean absolutely hold on okay then
we have cedric h five dollar super chat
shout out to you lord stop by to show
some love thank you sir we appreciate it
two more two more then we got sinjitsu
sage member for 13 months thank you my
brother
hey shout out everybody dropping by the
only thing elon musk hasn't bought yet
yes
he blew up my twitter i'm he blew up my
text
he going through it man he liked the
acquisition listen
if elon drops the bag off
yeah bro you might not be listening to
us
[Laughter]
on twitter
the lord's bought for 10 pieces of
silver
everborn soccer man of a man of taste a
man of a culture
a one is disrespect to steak if you ask
for a1 at morton's they'll probably ask
you to leave that is true
morton's is a steakhouse where they give
you the steak the way it's supposed to
be don't actually
don't say oh i want it well done they
will kick you out
mistake is meant to be medium rare
period what happened to the customer is
always right yeah what's that like
you gonna get the statement he told you
to get more nobody knows
how you gonna ask me for money yeah you
tell me i tell you how you will get it
gonna tell you
go to the internet
that's disrespectful
go go across the street and have a big
bring
[Music]
once again five dollars in the chat we
need a poll this blasphemy of eating mac
and cheese with the spoon membership in
the realm on the line listen it's pure
love that we have laura flame here like
you understand that you understand how
much we have love for this kid for even
to associate with him with this nonsense
that he deals with but thank you
yeah there you go
why don't you why don't you just go all
the way and get a spork instead
call me up for one of these nintendo
episodes i got my camera ready y'all
won't have to shame me don't doubt me go
ahead salute to the dumb i got a link
don't worry about it no doubt we got it
yeah
apparently flames leaving the door open
for everyone
we got sage once again
that sounded wild yeah
[Laughter]
gotta also show some love this way i'm
going to outbid him guys don't you worry
i'm contacting bruce wayne yes that
super power in the world rich
we got apollo cooper two dollars in the
chat what up lords wbg guy here but
loving the vibes thank you oh absolutely
thank you much love so look we got to
get into it a lot of show lined up but
uh it's that time of the month y'all
it's that time of the month where we do
that thing and we celebrate an amazing
team at lognet aka lordsofgaming.net
tremendous job for the entire team first
of all um the pax east coverage was
phenomenal attic was working super hard
to get get the coverage up as far as the
videos and then shout out to lognet
lawsongaming.net for really
transitioning out into article form
we've got crazy positive reception we
call it the war room internally you know
i'm saying and the war room was popping
because we had stuff to show y'all and
they they were killing it but um shout
out to everybody who killed that
editorial team everybody but it's time
to celebrate one particular lord you
know kind of went above and beyond in
the month of april tremendous month i
think he had like um
some really cool guys a tiny tina i
believe uh bloodstain child of light
review always does his cool little epic
games kind of roundups and just really
helping out with the with the news the
coverage and the write-up so we are
proud to present the latest winner of
the i
dizzy lognet scribe of the month for the
month of april joseph repco aka the
spoon man with mac and cheese
oh yeah
what's going on brother congratulations
fantastic month man you really you
really killed it the teams will take it
to you and uh we love we love the work
and the progression man so speech
well thank you very much for having me
on more to gaming um
like i want to be a little mushy i want
to say like throughout this entire year
since i joined in june like things have
changed my life like a lot and being
able to
write on the site and just
really evolved my writing and all that
kind of stuff it's been
very very transformative to me thank you
very much for having me love brother you
guys are awesome you're awesome too man
you have fun we love the energy you know
you got some spicy take some time but
that's just you that's you you don't say
it but at the end of the day now
seriously the work the quality of the
writing has been exceptional it was very
fierce with you and gene this month i go
live she was up there shout out to g
shout out to magic gene who pulled up
you know what i said for taking it
because gene went out there no g went
out there and it was a tough decision
just just so you know like a lot of
times these things are razor closed and
we just felt from the whole month you
know what i'm saying from a consistently
standpoint you really killed it but it
could have easily went to gene too
because you can be holding it down
what's up i can't i can't be involved in
these decisions flying cause i'm
corruptable
just paypal me a little something don't
you gotta do that much
that's that no double make sure
i could be a great politician man
you're ridiculous
yes you can anyway salute to you make
sure you hit up solve get whatever you
want from the store
yeah yeah and i'm good yeah i was just
gonna say uh we playing the same game
flames so if you need help with anything
just tell don't tell i literally had
like one thing it was like one little
resource you got to collect i could not
figure it out for the life of me i
figured out last night and i died a
little inside because it was so simple
oh it's called upgrading something
yeah yeah i started the whole game over
because of that
the game the game that shall be that
name under embargo correct that game yep
all right this is this is exactly boujee
talk guys this is the stuff that they
live for you know it's a game that i'm
playing that i can't even talk about it
it's just so crazy it's something crazy
that i have to mention
and thanks the lords of gaming.net
exactly so shout out to log net for
allowing us to have these opportunities
again flame enjoy your day and that's
right of the years heating up
competitions heat up this year a lot of
good contenders in the team but salute
[Music]
no doubt all right guys have a good one
enjoy it i gotta head to work hold on
get your work on get your work on bless
this song we got any more super chats
yeah yeah we gotta
yeah mr irishman member for 10 months
thank you sir
greetings lords looking forward to the
messiness the hogue versus schreier
debate got me added to the blocked list
oh wow jason must have gp numbers on
there wow
and then we have uh thx 1138 with the 50
dollar super bowl thank you so much
i see sage's 20 and i'll raise him 30. i
got tony starks on the line iop is life
totally stops in the building
man
what's up oh i was just saying man
we're good we're caught up we're good
all right dude let's get into this
poll okay
two weeks ago poll results are in and
the people have spoken with the latest
rumors of project tatanka being halo
infinite version of battle royale how
important do you think this mode is for
the halo infinite's long-term success
the winner very competitive vote 43
was yes halo infantis battle royal could
be huge gaining a new generation of halo
fans who are not fans of arena shooters
coming in at a razer close 37 in second
place was the messy lords i don't care
it's a huge missed opportunity for
master cheeks tv series not included
and his last place at 18 of the vote was
halo infinite needs to deliver on pc
fixes co-op forge and other content on
the base game as priority shout out to
all the lords who participated lord
addict where are you at with the battle
royal do you think the realm got it
right
i got it right
the round got right
like at the end of the day like battle
royale is a very popping genre and if
you release the game in 2022 that's a
first-person shooter you might need to
incorporate that mode into it to compete
it's like i said what about the halo
argument like does halo need it no but
does it need it to compete i would say
yes
um not fair enough no doubt see some
visitors coming through the realm you
know what i'm saying the legendaries
that let me show up capri i want to make
sure you can hear us make sure
everything's good with him
but um yeah we're going to get it there
we go let me get a bike check i can hear
you my check my check yes
is it the right one
i'm coming in here hot man you're
covered in hot we are the gamer cash the
xbox drive legend in the game
good to see you good to see you guys
look at this family back together back
together again man you already know so
we got some topics we gonna get into
like juicy show today so yeah this is me
um yeah xbox and bethesda showcase
announced shout out to the xbox wire
join us sunday june 12th for the
showcase we are excited to announce the
xbox and bethesda game showcase will
stream sunday june 12th at 10 a.m
pacific one eastern the lord's time
gotta like that okay the lord style
right there they know they know they
know what to
get on the show
exactly the show will feature amazing
titles coming from xbox game studios
bethesda and our partners around the
world it will include everything you
need to know about the diverse lineup of
games coming soon to the xbox ecosystem
including upcoming releases to game pass
on xbox and pc and then the legend
himself phil dominus maximus aurelius
spencer he said getting ready for events
spending time with studios reviewing
demos announcing scripts is one of the
most fun parts of this job i feel like a
fan who is sneak behind stage watching
the show get created i can't wait for
june 12th to show the amazing work of so
many teams so again like attic said
we're not gonna deep dive as far as like
what's gonna be on the show kind of vibe
but just kind of the announcement
and the
mark uh the bethesda and microsoft
combination again because there was some
talk about that and then the timing of
it so let's start with let's start with
the guess i do i'm sorry i do want to
throw a little thing on to it so please
we could i i'd like to talk about two
because i see a lot of like hype going
around that yeah like there's
people that feel like this is a make it
and break it uh conference and yeah i do
want to talk about whether or not you
think this is like the most important
conference they've ever had and like the
the expectations they need to achieve
you get what i'm saying so the
combination the expectation and the
combination of the uh potential let's
start with sean capri how we get yeah
what's up man oh man i am so pumped
about this it's one of those things that
we expect to happen but there really
wasn't a guarantee a lot of question
marks coming in if e3 was even happening
so is there an expectation for some of
these some of these companies to do it
so i'm glad that xbox and bethesda are
still at it they don't have to be
correct and i'm very curious to see what
happens with sony and nintendo at this
stage um but i'm so excited about this i
think i might fly in to see some friends
and kind of watch it together you know
but as far as attic's point i i feel
like we have to be careful with this
notion that every time whether it's an
election or a show it's like this is the
most pivotal one of our lives like how
about we save that for maybe one when it
is i don't i don't really think that it
is but it does represent an opportunity
if sony and or nintendo choose to not do
it just for them to be at a space where
gamers are expecting we're habitual in
nature we just like we're like a flock
it's like our migration it's that time
of season we're gonna just instinctively
take time off work we're gonna book some
time to to watch some conferences and
and get hyped about this stuff so i
don't i don't know but i do think that
it's important
not maybe not the most important i feel
like that was before i feel like we've
seen those before okay but it is an
opportunity there seems to be a tipping
point with the last quarter and the
sales we've talked lots about that it's
been it's been really good in xbox land
so now it's like okay step on the gas
here a little bit a lot of question
marks in xbox land right now that is is
star field it
is that the only thing
so it does seem like we'll get a lot of
star field this year especially with the
bethesda and xbox pairing back up again
but i'm i'm kind of hoping for some more
if you know what i mean no i feel you i
definitely hear you coming from sean
capri on that lord addict let's start
with you sir you know where you're at
the combination bethesda back again some
people thought maybe a separation there
and then uh yeah would you feel it don't
pressure i think i think next year we'll
probably see a separation uh because uh
that's when activision officially be
purchased like how i think they're gonna
do this is they're gonna do what's
like the next two years of all three of
them
like for instance like this is the
starfield showcase because that's the
biggest game
next year i'm gonna just throw a game
out there let's say overwatch twos
coming out next year and that's their
big game which obviously we don't know
what's going on there could be multiple
things coming out next year but nothing
is in stone so i feel like they'll
dedicate the show to that like i feel
like what they're going to do is it's
like the rest of this year and next year
we're going to dedicate the show to that
up until next year's events okay uh and
this year just so happened to be
starfield uh you know i i i do think
that it's an important conference that
they need to the only thing that's
that they need to do is make sure they
don't drop the ball like as long as they
do something like last year where they
they keep the momentum going that's the
important thing
just keep the momentum going don't drop
the ball
no i feel that
because it's you know they they go for
that that throw and you know they drop
the ball at the last bit no one's going
to care what happens two months from now
and especially you know how going from
you know what the state of halo is right
now too like they could use a a a w they
really can like regardless you know how
they say it's like the uh what's that
same where you you take away the eye
from what actually is
is the fire
it's like you know
halo is is definitely
in bad press right now so what you do
you you shine a giant spotlight on star
field and if it looks good
halo what ain't nobody by the time the
hype for star feels over halo will be uh
we'll hopefully get content out so
no fair enough i mean i hear what you're
saying i mean
i agree with you in a sense that i think
we all agree that when we saw the
imagery of the of the advertisement
we know what some of the focus is going
to
be and we would
just do that field good at it they
better show me game play i swear to god
they better show me
if they don't like look i can't play
this is a little what i'm sorry oh yeah
for sure guaranteed if there's no if
there's no game play at this i don't
care what the chat says i don't care
what king says no the whole stream the
whole stream hell wow
wow
already we already know i don't see gay
players star filled i am
i'm living
you got your pitchfork ready why did i
get that straight bullet just
oh yeah
y'all funny no doubt let's go straight
i got the bazooka aimed at you king
i don't know why
you're the one that's hyped for
starfield
we gonna get the kick soon we'll get the
kick soon
it's just when it comes down to it's
like look i do think this
this
what's this
this event is important because it's
going to show
what the xbox series x has in store i
think it's important as well because it
validates the concerns
that people have with purchasing these
studios now i the reason that i'm not
100 think it's like the most important
thing i think when you start seeing
the games that they make together that
hasn't already been in the pipeline
that's going to do more than just
showing what they've been working on for
three to four years and microsoft pulled
it in the last bit and just like how
much you want for this okay like i think
i think we need to the most important
thing is to see
how microsoft takes these studios and
improves them in their next projects
like the the outer worlds two
of k3 like whatever you know i would
even say the
elder elder scrolls six would be one of
them because uh they they they have a
little bit developed but it's not
anywhere pre-production so i do feel
like that type of game like when those
games start showing yeah that's when i
feel like is a little bit more on the
line because if those games are like
let's be real if star field doesn't
captivate the way people want it to
that then the number one excuse people
is going to use well attitude you know
that that that was that was before
but you know once once you know you
start seeing elder scrolls sixth game
play uh you know the outer worlds
hellblade two you start seeing a lot
more of these games there's no excuse
after that it's like this is them after
they've been bought
no no no doubt i hear where you coming
from lord solve man again the
announcement surprise and then you know
what how you feel about the combo
returning as far as the bethesda bike so
the branding of that another question
i've got to ask all of you is all
kind of like
physical event and stuff i want to get
into that as well if at any point that
will happen we know what's going on in
the world and stuff like that but let's
get your additional thoughts lord stop
um this is an interesting one for me
because
like if we if we look forward to 2023
and and the lineup is kind of the way we
expect it to be with a lot of these
games
that were sort of getting underway as
these you know as these teams were
joining microsoft then it's about time
to start coming out or show at the very
least showing and coming out so
it's one of those things where it's just
i have i don't know what their thinking
is because on one end they've said in
the past hey i think we've learned let's
not show stuff that's too far out right
so they want to be closer to to release
before they actually show anything of a
game on one end at the other end we have
seen stuff that you know elder scrolls
whatever the case may be these things
announce years and years in advance
right just to let people know it's
coming of course create a little bit of
hype
but i kind of don't know where they're
standing here so
when it comes to what i'm expecting this
year i'm honest i'm going in with a
blank slate i honestly i want to be
completely surprised
the the things that feel obvious to me
are like we were talking about
yes we need star field uh game play
right we need to do it for me it feels
like the todd thing where he comes out
he gives you the whole breakdown or
whatever
and stuff like that so
beyond that though i mean we've heard
rumors that maybe forza gets pushed we
don't know where hellblade stands we
don't know where compulsions game stance
so there's a lot of stuff that you know
if you think about it if it's not ready
this year and we start looking at the
potential slate for next year
when are they ready to talk about that
stuff so
honestly i i'm honestly kind of at a
loss to to kind of try to pinpoint what
i think might be there which is exciting
for me right um
but um yeah i honestly
they could they could drop
they could drop bomb after bomb after
bomb
of showing us what's coming out the rest
of this year and for all of next year
and that would be great or they could
they could sort of hold everything back
and maybe talk about lightly a few
things that are
way down the pipeline just kind of tease
those things or whatever so
honestly i i'm kind of
when i sat down and tried to think about
what it was i'm like you know what i
really don't know where they're coming
at this from so it's going to be fun i'm
going to be it's going to be an exciting
day that day because i'm really going in
blind i don't want to hear any of the
damn leaks already oh
yes i love you i don't know
the grubby grub
save it
the chat the chat's calling me out
they can't they don't ha if they didn't
show any uh gameplay of star field but
they had a very good showing of fable
you would contradict yourself
and you know what you know what
you damn straight up
on himself brought alert on himself
because we know that is true it'd be
it'll be like
[Laughter]
now imagine if they didn't show star
field gameplay and they showed fable in
a bad way
then i might leave the podcast yeah
you're you're in trouble you're in
trouble yeah yeah
real quick um
solve before passing the kick um about
the i'm sorry
yeah the physical event you wanted but a
little bit that and then also
do you think again we're assuming and
i've got to ask this question to sean um
we're assuming that
the activision situation will go through
right so if it does
next year's e3 2023
is it a situation where it's no longer
just that
and they maybe take away the bethesda
thing and then do other shows or is it
the microsoft bethesda activity like
what what what happens then i mean if i
were them i'd dominate the conversation
for two or three days
and break it up yeah
if there's that much content to talk
about
why not dominate the conversation for a
couple of days that's great nobody's
ever done that way it's like okay we're
coming back tomorrow with more stuff
that you haven't seen i actually feel
like
once activision's purchased they're not
trying to dominate the conversation for
two or three days they're trying to
dominate the conversation all year long
yeah
i think you're go you're going to see
like events every three or four months
you're gonna see exo they're gonna show
us up at the video game awards you're
gonna need to yeah you're gonna need to
so
no doubt no doubt let's get uh real
quick shark appreciate on that and then
we'll give king the floor for all the
thoughts i've got the astrologer so like
what do you think like with the looming
depending potential activision closing
what happens with the show branding the
title like how does that work for you
i'm i'm split on it actually and i could
see them kind of like slotting in
whichever one they want to highlight you
know like i'm wondering too if if
starfield is enough on its own to
justify the xbox and bethesda branding
that we're seeing like should we be
hinted are they insinuating that we're
gonna get more than that like are we
getting quake are we getting something
else up in here
is the bethesda just speaking to star
field or is there other stuff that we
can expect well i mean like we probably
see right fall there too so
right yeah and that and like again like
what justifies the co-branding right
like is it two games that's kind of what
i'm trying to do oh
and this thing so it's like that seems
like a lot that's a big deal that's it
and it's and the whole acquisition is
kind of old news at this point so like
at what point are they to your point
when do they just
roll it in it's all kind of the same
thing
i think i i could see them like if i ran
xbox this could be an xbox plus
whichever one we're given the spotlight
so make sure it could be activision it
could be it could be even like just
blizzard x and whichever one is going to
get the which everyone's going to get
that spotlight i wonder and i what i'm
on the fence on though is whether or not
they should dominate the conversation
for a whole weekend or just make a
really punchy 90 minute show
because i don't think like i think they
have to get there first before they
expand to
you
and like selfishly like is somebody who
enjoys most of what the shows that xbox
puts out there i'm like yeah i'll take
that for a week but you don't really
want the the chances the weeks pause for
people to go like i could have gone
without like this hour over here or this
half an hour over here
just make it like super concentrated
first and then start to expand but even
right now like we've kind of seen we we
need we need more concrete dates we need
more like of a calendar
uh for for xbox to be in and it's a
completely different area that nintendo
was in but they tell you about one game
and they're just going to tell you about
kirby and kirby and kirby yes yes until
kirby's out and next i'm sure they'll be
um you know battles um strangers i'll
take it y'all take it when nintendo put
out one game and talk about the one game
you know what microsoft i'm listening to
all you doing oh here we go
the interesting part about this is in
the industry we we've never had a
platform or be in this kind of position
that is true it's just like
it's not a matter of if they have stuff
to show it's not even a matter of when
they have to stuff the show it's a
matter of do they have enough time to
show it yeah yeah that's a good point to
you know sean capri's point in reference
to the bethesda branding he's almost
saying like yo but that's the i mean we
kind of know stop it right but like if
you're gonna use that name what else are
you doing to from your catalogue from
your studios yeah when you think about
what could potentially be shown just on
the bethesda side
you have indiana jones you have
wolfenstein you have you have i've heard
rumors of quake coming back give it to
me yeah so it's like they they have
they could potentially have enough for
their own showcase right mm-hmm so yeah
i mean i think to sean's point i think
and alvin and the chat sort of agreed he
wanted a one big mega show where they
sort of show everything quickly
and then throughout the week they do
smaller breakdown shows i think did xbox
do that i think with gamescom last year
where they had the the initial
presentation like opening night
presentation
they had paris sit down later
[Music]
yeah i think
i think they'll eventually fade that out
like i think the only reason they're
doing it right now is a show a shine of
respect
seeing people falling out though well no
i'm not talking i'm talking about just
the naming
concept like yeah but that's then
microsoft show like i think they're
doing it because it's a sign of respect
but will you after they buy activation
they're going to say microsoft
activision but that is let's say they
buy sega in the future the microsoft
division
i think right now because it's a it's a
show respect you know let's be real here
but this is carrying the studios at this
point in this current time so it's like
look you got you got the highlight you
got the you got the keystone
you got the one we going to carry their
own stuff they had to get purchased to
get carried
oh god you guys are killed hey what
because the stuff was out right now
what's carrying it
what's carrying the gears what's
carrying the halo
you don't want this in the shape
microsoft has to do this and microsoft
but nintendo could come out with kirby
and y'all like word that's dope
here we go we're not gonna act like
anyone on this panel has said anything
about kirby ever man he just said
that kirby
i'm talking are you oh you need the same
podcast that i'm watching you said i'm
talking about the awards we have never
capped for that game there goes the goal
post anyway i mean
you you you can make the comedy jokes
all you want
well if they don't show game play it's
whack but then if they show zelda it's
dope yo
you're like okay okay how are you gonna
do it listen this is the reason why they
don't listen to none of y'all oh lord
they say
we're gonna we're gonna put i know i
know i know
they're gonna put together the show the
way they're gonna put together the show
right they're not gonna give y'all all
the kitten kabuto that everybody do you
know how they never do it they never do
yeah
they all shows and we sit there like
they're gonna run this off they can
write that out they're gonna let this
off they're gonna write that up
you i said the same things you said
so i've just used your own words against
you and you
i lost youtube are you guys good oh
let's check this accent connection yeah
we good we're good yeah
did you play the baby
still in the box
don't do his router like that don't
just busted
of our foolishness you know what do you
think first about the announcement the
name
association with bethesda and also a
potential physical event well yeah
i thought it would be gone this year but
then i also didn't know about the uh
huge acquisition of um activision that
sovereign uh astutely predicted and knew
about before anybody said a word so all
you cap is out there talking about that
i did say that i said you said nothing
solved it right that is true
the only way spoken into existence send
those words of uh stuff over this to
solve the solve gets those ocular it's
not you kind sir anyway
um
if if they weren't under scrutiny right
now
it'll be the xbox show oh
they're under scrutiny right now so i
agree they want to show uh the ftc yo we
play nice with people see
we got them and they still independent
they still doing their own thing
we did we we didn't make her get rid of
her last name
[Laughter]
next year she go the papers are just
going to say xbox
i agree
i don't think i don't think it's like
for like that kind of logistics like i
do think king has a point in you know
saying that you know these people are
still going to work in on independent
fashion but i think i think it's more of
just like look like you know a lot of
your games are in our conference because
if i think it felt like king if it was
that way like i feel like they wouldn't
have named it last year like if they
didn't have the last year
last year was uh a lot of butt hurt uh
other dudes that's on the blue team
was uh what's happening what does this
mean for us yeah i have to buy
another console you don't have to
support another child
you pregnant and you're gonna support
this baby
that's it
you got
[Laughter]
the biggest thing is finance uh-huh so
they won't be straddled with no new baby
they don't want that that little baby
they have no choice you want star phil
go get an xbox oh i got a high-powered
pc you're lying don't get an xbox
so we're not gonna do that right there
we already shout a little bit i honestly
believe
if activision wasn't in the in in the
clouds you know right they can really
get done
it just been the microsoft show and yeah
starfield they would have had a whole
thing with todd howard and all this
other stuff talking about the game
because it's a big game coming out this
year that everybody's gonna get a chance
to uh understand and know about and i
think that was probably one of the focal
points at this show they're gonna have a
lot of demos of other stuff like red
fall and other games like that stuff
that they announced and we can actually
see game play of it
i don't honestly think we're going to
see game player hey um fable
um yeah
yeah
i think we're going to see gameplay of
that we're going to get a release date
for that i don't know
um
i honestly believe this is those are the
reasons why
uh and and and they have to show
that they didn't lose their identity
right right that they still acknowledge
the entity that they purchase
because that shows
oh they're good people right they're
still right they didn't absorb them and
just you know push that to the side and
then just a name or a logo on the box
right they actually show
they're gonna have a presentation at the
show and i honestly also think and and
it i may be wrong let's go but the
advertising team over at bethesda
got one microsoft team and i think they
have a lot of say yeah
and i hope so yeah well that's why i
think it's more of a respect that's why
i think it's a moral respect well and
but there was we have to remember there
was two conferences before so people
don't want to feel like one was taken
away right i think it's more i don't
know if it's an
fcc i i'm canadian i don't know what
that is
i don't think as much as i think they
still just look at the actual business
side of it the transactional side of it
this is more of a gamers you used to get
a bethesda thing over here it's now over
here like again people were habitual but
they're comfortable with the habits yeah
let me ask you this okay what happens
the same that asks lordship capri what
happens next year assuming the
activision board
i believe that is the microsoft show
okay so you know so then now because i
think there's two big acquisitions
that's going to happen okay i think the
the one big acquisition with activision
is going to go through and i think the
ubisoft thing is going to follow
right after such
um so
it's going to be it wouldn't make any
sense next year to be like well it's the
xbox uh ubisoft show it's the xbox you
know it's just the xbox like i said that
[ __ ] could get really long yeah
it'll get tired some at some point in
time because you you're like phil
dominator
really expensive no no he earned that
and that's it um
but
listen man they they have a lot of
studios so if you start highlighting
only bethesda and you keep putting
bethesda what happens when your other
studios that you purchase that weren't
under the bethesda banner like yo what's
up man you know we the coalition man
what's up man
you know why why do they get a separate
show they're all published then you
start you start putting i mean
you know so you can't do that you have
great studios that are working on other
games
there and i think you have to do away
with the cold title stuff and just
actually start marketing these
developers because now you have enough
developers where you can be like okay so
this developer is working on this at
microsoft instead of just saying
microsoft in conjunction they under on
one umbrella okay
you have to think about who who's
following all this stuff we know that
bethesda equals xbox i think this is
just a super good pointer thing
not everybody knows this is e3 you know
or e3 timing so it's trying to bring
everybody in so if you're not following
along this is where everybody is i think
that's going to be a challenge when they
buy more to that point like it's like
how do you communicate that without
putting it as this ridiculously long
title
no what happens is microsoft controls
the whole week
of mp3
and i get i want that i just think
people are a little sensitive about the
time that is demanded of them how dare
they give me a three hour thing how dare
they make me watch this thing all week
and i think that can be tricky they
could have these things where they have
90 minutes on a sunday and a monday and
a tuesday but again i know you guys
don't want to talk about nintendo but
like that treehouse stuff is there for
people who are obsessive about i want to
know how this menu stuff works so don't
tell me about the the catapults in in
age of empires during the thing i'm
trying to get hyped about
carve that out somewhere else and i
really do think they could have hype
show for 90 minutes and then nine hours
of stream yeah something else like just
getting into nitty gritty stuff yeah i i
agree good then i'll go i feel like the
stuff that's in like the treehouse stuff
like i feel like that is what they need
to direct towards the inside xbox
program totally
they they need to take all of their game
play like you know i'm a big advocate on
like pulling stuff from the video game
awards i know it's important but i i've
always been one of the kind of person
if you're building up other people's
stuff you're never going to truly build
your own stuff
it's just like when it comes to showing
game play on fable for the first time
you know you show that on the big stage
because we ain't seen it but when you
start talking about the features in the
game and the places in the game that's
on inside xbox agreed
yeah i mean you guys make a lot of good
points i mean
it's interesting because i was surprised
when i first saw the naming convention
once again you know but that's the
microsoft okay cool but to show him a
good point i do think it's it's more of
a reinforcement to the casual person
that hey
but that's the it's part of us they're
associated with us and now they have
stuff to show so to me it does make
sense but i am with king long term
because he's to get too much at some
point right activision you know
blizzard dumb alone right it's just a
monstrous amount of titles and stuff
like that so um yeah i think i think
we're getting to a point where they are
growing substantially
i think it's going to get to a point
where 90 minutes just cannot contain
all this realistically right really
they're going to take advantage of
platforms like xo they're probably going
to bring that back right because it's
just like look like it's like i said i
don't think it's going to be one of
those things where whatever we're doing
we're going to add whoever to who's do
do headlights show like like i said next
year blizzard or activision does
something because if you use that
mentality every year is going to be
right microsoft and call of duty
microsoft and call of duty microsoft and
call of duty i think it's just going to
be one of those things where it's like
look starfield is going to be our heavy
hitter this year that's what we're going
to leave the show with that's going to
be the captivating thing and we're going
to build the show up to that in the next
year it doesn't matter on where it came
from it matters on what's writing what's
realistically able to show at this time
and i also think it's going to be a
situation where it's going to be part i
think you're not going to like addict
though i think there's going to be a
situation where there's going to be
trade-offs based on like you said what's
ready and where to show it i'm with you
i prefer
them use that secondary show kind of
like how they did with paris last year
you know shout out to lord paris where
you know it was a little good show right
a little breakdown and you could go
deeper with it the question becomes
who gets what because i know people
don't like to hear but lord jeff keagle
is outside
you know and summer games fest is a big
thing and microsoft has shown
that they are willing to kind of pivot
and put some of their bigger titles
bigger announcements on the game awards
i know on a twitch right so now you're
going to get to that thing where
decisions are going to be made i'm with
you i would love microsoft to keep that
stuff in-house but also not realistic
realistic analytics are analytics right
and if they are the number one showcase
or whatever the question becomes
like with a star field is it a situation
where you get a 10-minute thing and then
it's like yo
tune in the job
if you want you know the breakdown it's
going to be interesting to see how they
handle
reveals this year that's the cure and i
agree with soft there's a ton of
unpredictability this year because
there's so much they're in transition
with a lot of these acquisitions and
also what's ready right and how much do
you show it and is the focus which i
think would be
more so not that they won't show
anything in the future but i think
because i think 2023 is going to be
like ridiculous i don't think people are
ready for it i think 2023 is going to be
ridiculous
but my thing is i think they are going
to have more of a 2022
focus razor sharp what you're getting
this year let me stop because i'm doing
prediction stuff but oh also the k i
want to talk about is um physical event
you know we're hearing rumblings right
you know does fan fest come back like
what what have now they haven't probably
it's it's made now so it's probably not
it's not enough time if he's going to
organize that but it i i'm getting the
vibe that they're putting feelers out to
see
what's going on and uh yeah send little
represent the laws if y'all wanna you
know
[Laughter]
just say it just say it right i'm the
only one gonna be able to go yeah
bank is ready to purchase that ticket
right now no no no just saying it you're
gonna be coming in hot for free okay
700 here hit the like button please just
hit the like we rarely say that but yeah
it really does help the algorithm and
i'm gonna start saying it all the time
don't i say that because i i'm not doing
that for the i'm doing that for me
for me
for him
every time they hit the like button a
new sony player sends in their ear
ridiculous anyway anyway thank y'all
that's what i got that will probably get
them to hit the like button quicker
quicker
no doubt anything else before we move on
to this song some chats
all right we're good so i'm getting some
chats with cancer there's a lot of
we got uh sage with the 55 super chat oh
no you don't thx 1138 don't let me dig
into the u.s treasury bonds now
i think yeah this is where the betting
stopped 55 stage one thank you
appreciate that
there we go necromancer zell ten dollars
if you chat xbox's 2022 showcase needs
to be big but 2023 needs to be huge they
have a future lineup uh the future
lineup updates that they need to share
however 2023 showcase will fill out the
xbox platform future
perhaps that's for sure
then we got gas with the 10 pound super
chat welcome back thank you sir thank
you so much
and we got dead planet five dollar super
chat it better not be above xbox to put
gameplay for a game we see for the first
time at the show why not compulsion in
exile id machine game etc yeah i mean
it's fair to assume that some of those
games are pretty far along yes so can we
see game play sure
do they usually talk about that on the
fifth and next month
exactly i'll give them all the bars
then we got ko3 black truth ten dollars
super chat okay though three of them
okay
black
truth
shout out to the best podcast on earth
much respect to the realm appreciate
what you bring to this industry keep
blessing us with great content and to
smoke thank god thank you brother much
love
then we got donald taco five dollars if
we chat i feel like either way the show
will need to be split i think they
should have one show entirely for first
party and then one for third party xbox
game pass releases
i would work too to sort of spotlight
those games
and we got clutch man 20 show game play
then we got clutch man 20 live super
chat off topic we'll catch the show
later for the formula drift fans forza 8
should have a drift campaign with voice
overs from the commentators jared deanda
and ryan sage and the main campaign with
the original top gear guys is this like
a dream or just what you is what you
want i think no no i'm just saying i
don't know if this is what you think
you're gonna have they should stop
selling you cars that are 40 bucks
good let's start there oh
there we go apollo cooper two dollars
super chat it was all cool until king
came at my boy kirby oh yeah he
disrespectfully kirby today very
different geez he's worse than metroid
if you don't shut up
jesus he definitely eats out in the
bushes
there we go mr irishman with the five
pound super chat did you guys see that
randolph iv insider say that he heard
almost virtually every xbox studio
submitted something for the june show
yes it's true
here we go advise everyone to turn their
mics down like they they
so what what kind of fable is acceptable
to you oh lord
you know this kid gonna get emotional
with this damn my my my the kind of
fable that's accepted to me is
come on the fifth the next month and
you'll see y'all setting them up
y'all setting them up because if they
don't show it
throw tomatoes at the screen
out the rock excalibur
it is gonna go like this and say fable
you'll find you'll find out on the fifth
of next month what my uh what what my
acceptable fable coverage they're going
to show the fairy after she got
swallowed by the turtle
moving on
microsoft will literally call it the
xbox bethesda and activist showcase next
year they don't care how long it is it
isn't a product it's just a showcase
that makes sense you say that i guess
you say that now
because that because technically it's
activision blizzard
that it so yeah so it's gonna be uh you
know and then uh if king's dream comes
true and they buy ubisoft so we're
looking at uh microsoft xbox bethesda uh
bethesda's
bethesda activision blizzard ubisoft
showcase
i feel like i feel like just three is
too much guys i'm gonna be wrong doesn't
that make it worse on the whole ft ftc
thing because it makes it worse it's
like xbox we got all this that's way
worse
it don't they got money
there we go
elections would be over no more
grandstanding one dude was out the way
now let's slide in the next dude
savage savage
they won't have a word to say with you
we sort of watch and it's just gonna go
through and dude's gonna be like i'm
just gonna let this happen
they wouldn't even be in first place
even with the activision thing as well
it's kind of funny
you know what's crazy if they buy
ubisoft how many how many senators you
think is going to be tagged in that
tweet none
because the elections is over they don't
care
there's no grandstanding
there's no soapbox to stand on anybody
microsoft is being bad because they're
buying stuff that's bad and making it
good
[Laughter]
how dare they hell
how dare they use their money to fix the
industry
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
chat all i want to see is king lose his
ish during the showcase
on the xbox now the biggest question the
biggest question i have to the chat
is do you think blaze 4k need to be in
that live stream oh lord
moving on he's showing up on that show
but i'll show over sony do something
because
i play flame beard messy five dollars
honestly i hope we see the release date
for halo infinite coming out of early
access
i know i know we're a decade away so
i'll get disappointed yeah that was
crazy shout out to sage he's out of
control
all right there we have done we have ham
solo gaming shout out to himself hold on
i gotta jump gotta go back to him solo
two dollar super chat hello on my way
back from midwest gaming
on that six-hour drive
trip
then we got mr two opinionated five
dollar super chat
i'm usually with my soccer account
i'm usually with you king but wb is
greater than ubisoft in my opinion
ubisoft should be an ea access style
deal instead what kind of work
okay first first they already told you
that that ea access style deal is coming
anyway but they also showed you other
things that shows you where we have a wb
topic right but hold on just i just want
to say because he he used his money to
voice his opinion so i have to give him
a rebuttal
um
ubisoft only
uh has the developers all right and the
license agreements and stuff like that
is what you're looking for
y'all have to really understand just
because you get this you don't get that
you're buying a ferrari maker you're not
getting a ferrari you understand they
don't have the license for that so
you're just gonna have a car a no-name
car that he has to make something they
have to make something in that ilk so
i don't see wb as dope y'all do is keep
fighting for this wb oh i we need a
superhero game you're trying to outdo
sony really quickly
we'll have batman and we could go up
against that spider-man any day sucker
no i don't like that i don't know i
can't wait for my my voice at the time
that would be topic i i don't i don't
think people are wanting them to make
like a superhero
thing to like combat spider-man i think
they just want to play superhero game
but then go on playstation
because i get this in my dms all the
time 90 of the dir do you think marv
spiderman i mean you think uh uh xbox is
working on a superhero game king do you
king
i know you know they're working on the
punisher first person yeah yeah
it sounds like people want it
yeah i hear that right that you have to
blow up sounds like people want it yeah
i hear that but again
you can say yo
uh we were like a marvel game obviously
the people with a relationship oh yeah
making this stuff i think this these
guys are more of a percentage in the
area that you should do that so if
you're looking for that how about you
buy a playstation and just you know you
never understood your opposition to this
yeah it's always so aggressive
like i don't understand why they they're
just not allowed to make those type of
games just just go just don't go out of
your way blowing the bank trying to make
a spider-man
equivalent it's like it's like king has
like some contract yeah
but i think there's some internal deal
that he got you cannot talk about that
one i want god forbid i want like a
punisher on xbox
[Laughter]
bethesda brings quick con and abk brings
blizzcon i wonder if those shows will
have more announcements you know what
that's a very good point because those
are big shows that again
now that they're
they're going to have more stuff to talk
about who knows that those shows just
become bigger and they become more of
announcement shows and with blizzcon
particularly there's a lot of bad press
around that show that they would do well
to fix yes so um yeah that that is not a
bad idea at all
that sounds good what else we got then
we have sage once again 10 super chat in
that case if they buy other publishers
they'll use a parenthesis
and a featuring xbox game studios
bethesda activision blizzard with
microsoft gaming showcases headlines
yeah
it's gonna keep going and you're gonna
have to get that dude that does the
voicing for all ufc
no my god we got hearty chinny again
target chinese
[Music]
he about the message
so we all caught up sir yeah we're good
we're all right cool let's get into this
second time it's alex do you want me to
set you up here yeah set me up because
i'm gonna be real with you i don't
remember what my talk
so look we got to talk about our ps5
oh that's what it is yeah i remember now
yeah let me set you up i got you i got
you trials and also to stack it dig but
um yeah shout out to
gamedeveloper.com according to sources
their sources developers working on
games that have a wholesale cost of 34
or higher are now required to create
time limited game trials of their games
on the uh playstation plus premium
subscribers the trial versions must be
at least two hours long games that cost
lower than these amounts are not
required to create the limited time
trials according to the new policy many
developers were informed about this new
policy via an update to sony's
development developer portal and it says
that um
the good news is that these requires are
not retroactive do not apply to upcoming
playstation vr titles the less great
news is that if you're a developer plan
to release on the playstation store you
need not you need not need to budget
time and resources to create these uh
new time trials there is some
flexibility developers have up to three
months after their games launched on the
playstation store to release their time
trial trials are also only required to
be available to playstation plus premium
users for at least 12
months but um yeah they they say in the
demos the game trial thing and um it
said that it will be approved on a k as
far as the release dates on the case by
case uh basis developers are also still
free to publish free weekends game
trials or customer demos that can be
accessed by all playstation orders so
this was a hot one as well as the
stacking
your topic at it go for it man
so i do want to add something else that
happened to this talk about playstation
plus in some way
um it looks like uh you know i want to
throw this in there like this little
sprinkle for king
it looks like it looks like my uh that
sony is stopping people from stacking
playstation plus
so uh i know a couple people that bought
some that didn't let them so you know i
want to just throw that part in there do
you think that you know that's something
they should be doing and i want to start
with king let's see
do you think they should stop them from
spending money
with them
this is how petty they are
dudes will literally stack to get five
six years of their service
to get in i want to lock in with you at
the price that you got already yeah
today's probably saying yesterday
[Laughter]
you had an update this morning
we removed that completely
so you're not honoring the amazon cards
and none of that
none of that when we roll it out in june
you're gonna get the full price
dudes thought they was gonna do the
xboxes you know xbox is a dollar because
i got my xbox and i just stacked it and
i had brought in
i'm a genius i'm a genius no see this is
what good business dude they knew that
you weren't going to engage they said go
ahead genius engage
go ahead your genius lock yourself in
for seven years you with us these other
dudes they knew how smart you were and
said nah stop him now make sure that he
pays at the door
his credit don't look good make sure
that he's locked in for the full
caboodle but sony i've been here day one
i'm your number one fan yeah um make
sure that you play at the door um
it's me jacob yeah uh jim um
make sure that guys
damn
thank you
nothing for the fans it's nothing for
the players this it's for the payers oh
damn if you want to get down with their
service get in
you ain't stacking and you mad but where
you do that you're none of your dudes is
outside screaming microsoft did this
stop the stacking y'all be outside with
pitchforks microphone stop this guy
so he told you that y'all couldn't stack
that i was like well i guess we're not
stacking
i will say that if it was microsoft that
prevented you from stacking the uh
game pass ultimate i do think people
would this would be covered in in all
torns of media outlets i feel like this
wasn't really brought like it's like it
bro it was mentioned and then people was
like oh we don't care
shout out to eurogamer.net for context
they said this week playstation plus
subscribers found that they were unable
to redeem prepaid voucher cards and
extend their subscription time even if
it was about to run out bewildered
customers were told the situation was
temporary but not giving further
instructions now sony has updated its
fact page for its upcoming playstation
plus changes and acknowledge a move that
said for now you'll only be able to
redeem prepaid vouchers you bought after
your current planning playstation plus
membership expires you'll see you know
it's funny they're like it's temporarily
it's temporarily until we launch the
oh and new
quote if you currently have a
playstation plus or playstation
membership due to changes we are making
to the service prior to launch you won't
be able to redeem a voucher code for
that service until your existing
membership expires and deactivates that
is if you think about it that is insane
that is crazy that's new you are not
godfather then
you will not get to the premium team
you will stay basically
i do want to point out that they're kind
of doing something similar to this with
fundamentation and crunchyroll like
what's going on is uh if you're in
because i'm in funimation so let's say i
got grandfathered into the old price
because i was uh with fundamental when
they had the older price
so like i pay like 4.99 or something
it's like ten dollars a month now or
something like that yeah no no no no
it gets it gets worse
so you know
they buy a fun dimension they buy from
crunchyroll they're like you know what
we're gonna do
we're gonna go ahead
and merge everything from fundamental to
crunchyroll okay do you think i got that
that price when i went over to
crunchyroll sony owns them
yeah sony owns both for them do you
think i got that price when i wanted
anything here
guess what guess what they are doing on
fundamentation they're saying yo what
are they doing after they're saying look
we know that there's some games that
this tv shows you like on there once
that series is finished that's it you
ain't getting nothing else so they're
pretty much saying if you want the new
stuff the new animes the new episodes
you have to go to crunchyroll
they're pretty much
they're
they're they they're they're anime
keeping man they're anime keep it anyway
let's get let's get a little short and
freezing basic man i'm curious about the
uh both bits of news you know in
reference obviously the stacking which
we just talked about and then obviously
but the big one i think the um the whole
game trials thing and the requirement
and where you're at with this whole
thing with the playstation plus premium
seems kind of tone deaf i think doesn't
it like on all fronts well i mean it's
in it's in a good intention trying to
give players who are the premium price
point trying to give them a little
little value there so the intention is
there and it's nice and and maybe it'll
drive some people to go there but it's
it is gatekeeping in a certain way that
for everybody less than that like only
the top people are getting this cool
thing so people who are that baseline
stuff it's like ah what are you doing
that for so it it's making it it's just
completely falling on its own head it's
not really land i can't imagine it's
it's landing well with developers i
can't imagine it's landing well with
two-thirds of the of the tiers
who are not going to
really benefit from this at all and it
just seems like it was a decision that
was made at a point in time when
playstation was like free and clear
they're going to just run away with
another generation
and i don't know if that's really the
case i feel like everything changes in
just in a matter of weeks with supply
being an issue um and xbox may be making
up some ground here i think it's just
really interesting to see
them make a move like this and on the
the stacking side
you'll get a second job it feels a lot
like you'll just get a get another job
just get the higher price point like
because you'll it's so good that you'll
you'll pay for it um i think it's going
to push
developers to either reduce their output
on playstation maybe move over
completely to xbox i think this is going
to be a little bit tricky for them
because it's like playstation is so good
you're going to jump over all these
hoops to get your games on here and
there's just too many options there's
too many options for devs to make games
for other platforms and
have a benefit so but in the
in the end though i don't know if it
really matters what really any of us
think like personally i think it's a
mistake i think in the long run both of
these topics are gonna hurt sony and
these things start to to add up as
developers will maybe move maybe make
less it'll take them longer maybe you
have like a
a phased approach of when these games
even launch do you have a go landing
first on xbox because it's easier to do
it there and eventually they'll they'll
push something over to playstation i'm
not really sure
but i think overall like they don't
really have the experience or even the
belief or buy-in into this recurring
business
they don't know how it really works so
they don't know how to like how to
leverage it in the best way possible
they're just thinking dollars and cents
and pocketbooks on this so everything
that they're doing is so short term it's
like we better make sure this next
fiscal is going to look okay but
everything they're doing actually is
pushing long-term business away
especially on that on the on the
stacking thing you should be happy to
have people just like lock in for the
next 40 years you
there it's too much of an assumption to
say that yeah they'll be back next year
as well
where xbox believes in if you're just
like if you're in the ecosystem if you
if i'm not getting i literally have game
pass until mid 2024 like i'm good for
literally years so i'm gonna be spending
money with them sony i don't think
really sees what the benefit of that is
or they can't project the financial
benefit of having somebody in your
ecosystem turning on your system all
like for the next two and a half years
and all the other money that you're
going to be spending there they don't
see it so i think their actions speak to
that kind of inexperience if i can say
that yeah no i hear where you're going
there's one other part of information i
forgot to to bring out as far as this
developer portal stuff that they're kind
of privy to there was also a statement
um saying that places plus will still be
required for multiplayer and they said
that um also if your game is free to
play you have to offer significant and
measurable ongoing benefits to
playstation plus members in order to be
free
so this is another more rules yeah this
is another little wrinkle that a lot of
people now talk about again there's a
people these are playgrounds got too
many barriers
and non child proof caps on everything
their house is all
boarded up you ever been to one of those
people house they got a brand new baby
and everything got rubber baby bumpers
on everything like they child will not
hurt their self at all it literally
could fall down the steps and just roll
out and just laugh because everything is
cushioned and it seems like sony is
burying everything
there's a barrier for everything with
them and they're falling over themselves
instead of allowing looking at what
other people have done
and just
emulate
emulate in your fashion and then they
just keep on doing this and it's getting
worse you just
i don't even know if i like the tier
system to begin with
to be honest with you like even when it
was announced i don't even know if
people have been calling for that for
for xbox for a long time like get
different tiers and i just think it's
hard to i think it's hard to message i
think you have to it forces you to
create differentiation between each of
the three pieces you have to create
value so they're they kind of back
themselves into a corner here like how
do we justify this big cost we're not
doing day and date games for first party
studios jim said like the middle tier
like
like who will want the middle tier it's
a medium fries that's what that is it's
just there it exists so that you go well
just for a little bit more i'll get the
top tier right like it's it's a total
classic it's an age-old marketing
manipulation kind of thing not that
they're really manipulating we all kind
of see through it let me know i think
that's why one thing to my is sam alton
he's like yo you literally have to pay
for xbox live to access demos and trials
on xbox what's the difference stop with
the um bs fake you call us xbox advances
that's funny um what the difference is
this again he's right about the service
part for the requirement but the they're
making an additional step in saying that
you your game from a developer
standpoint has to offer sig if you're
free to play you have to offer
significant and measurable ongoing
benefits to playstation plus members so
that that's a difference it's saying
that you have to also provide this extra
value and what does that entail that's
the difference and that's the problem if
the game itself um acting as a way to
keep people playing on playstation isn't
enough and it should be enough in and of
itself because then you're there and
then you go buy the next game and you go
spend money on the thing like it should
be that should be enough so it's kind of
the whole messaging here is that what
what everybody is doing isn't enough and
you need to step it up a little bit
right to get gloves and players you get
more yeah you want it you step up you
pay for it all that stuff no doubt no
doubt god's solving that we got yourself
too he gets you i was gonna say that the
sad part about this too
is it's just like i didn't really see
anyone talking about this like it was
one of those things where certain people
brought it up but it was just
it's just like this is something serious
like they're literally telling
developers uh we want to
splice your game when you give it to us
and we want to sell part of a
like i think they said two hours we want
to sell part of your game on our
subscription service and
obviously we don't know if they're
getting paid for it i would hope they
are but it's just like and no one
brought it up you know playstations
literally going out there they've been
lighting stacking for years literally
years they've let people stack but now
they're stopping it because of their own
messaging that they could have easily
remedied before they did this
and then instead of coming i'd be like
yo okay we messed up we're just gonna
have to hold that out like we're just
gonna have to like first off how many
percentage of people actually knew to do
something like this i would say it's not
a huge portion like a very small
percentage of people knew you could do
this right
it's like one remember when microsoft
messed up and they offered games
[Music]
they honored some of those people the
people that got in at the very end
beginning it's just like look like like
i get it playstation is a lot of
people's favorite platform but i didn't
like the energy i i i honestly feel like
no one said nothing about this
facebook
playstation angry lock face shout out to
face 23 bkly that's the homie he said
you guys are talking about it like it's
been confirmed when you guys discussing
rumors it's doom and gloom this is from
developers from the portal this is from
developers that i know have it so i'm
just letting you know and it's from the
gamedevelopers.com as well so again if
you don't choose not to believe it
that's on you but this is coming from
developers themselves about these new
requirements basically the portal got
updated
from if you're making games with sony
and this is the stuff they're saying so
hey if you don't believe me and it's not
like sony would come out and announce
this
after they signed the contract to put
the game or did it get updated before i
don't know one thing
that that you know you already signed a
prenup and then you go back and see
somebody erase something
wait wait it didn't say this yesterday
yesterday it didn't say that they get
all my money
so
you wake up it is an update to the
update
this is the this is the beauty of sony
not only are the consumers being
bamboozled
so are the developers
and that's what i'm saying and the best
part about it is sony is playing both of
y'all against each other y'all talking
about y'all need to support the devs and
buy the devs game at 70 bucks y'all been
fooled into believing this this is the
thing
y'all like yeah and the developers have
been buying into we got to put our games
into their service
y'all are the direct competition with
the people you try to support but both
of y'all are being bamboozled by the
same guy sony this is masterful work i
see your work i love it go ahead jim
keep going baby
let's get some he's been patient where
you at with this whole thing the
playstation game trials premium for the
premium service and uh no more stacking
right now
i mean when it when it comes to the
trials i think sean
summed it up perfectly perfectly when he
says
it it feels like on the surface they're
doing what microsoft is doing but when
it comes to the monetization of it they
don't understand the long game or they
don't care to understand the long game
they want they want to try their hand at
it's like there's not going to be a
playstation 6.
here we go
they want you it's a word it's a joke
the word engagement doesn't seem to
matter to them right now they're doing
what microsoft's doing on the surface
but the underlying ideology is not the
same they still want to charge you a
premium amount for pet for small things
whereas microsoft is willing to be like
here just take it
and i think
that's where that's where the failure
can be because what happens is that when
you start
making those comparisons and you start
it really does feel like you're being
nickel and dimed for every little thing
so when you look at the game trials
right
if they were gonna do this
the right way to do it is to put it at
your bottom tier the base ps plus tier
because that's the way that it
technically has been before on the xbox
360 pretty much every game had to have a
demo on it right and that was every
single game that was the base here
everybody had access to that
on steam i think it's kind of the same
and i could be wrong about that
but when you're telling me that your
demos are at the utmost highest tier of
your service you have to pay to get this
on the one end as a
as a dad
as a dev you probably see something from
that right but there is a lot of
responsibility associated with that but
the thing is i think as a whole when you
look at how we look at demos today the
thing about it is that
it's a demo is a it's a thing of a time
and place to me when you look at it
when you have game pass as the
comparison where everything is a demo
like everything everything's refundable
by the way good point everything's
refundable
everything is a demo right everything on
game pass is a demo you can play it for
20 hours you can play it for 20 minutes
and
when you have that as the baseline of
what can be
the the space for demos
this in comparison doesn't make a whole
lot of sense it doesn't actually go let
me interrupt you real quick what about
for
devil's advocate you know the financial
models are different so to sean's point
you know the the short-term money versus
the long-term money right so it's like
since they they care they're not in
position let's just say to do that
financially with game pass and the day
and date and all that stuff what if this
is
according to the books you know what
they got to do right and and sometimes
and we we've known microsoft to make
that mistake about sometimes you wonder
like is there a human in the room that
made this decision or is this is this an
algorithm that made this decision and
and because when you look at it it's
like
it just doesn't look good and and listen
the place they say the playstation name
may be so strong that it does not matter
in a lot of ways it may not even matter
right we would just whatever whatever
it's not going to be something that that
that
that causes them to really stumble and
clearly didn't matter no one really
talked about this right so to my point
so it it is that thing of like it may be
a subject of conversation for a little
bit longer and that's it um
but i in the long term it makes me feel
like they don't have
they they're doing this to say hey we're
doing it too
and honestly i feel like if in two years
it's it's a failure they're gonna
they'll they'll sweep it on the rug and
that's it and they don't care and and
it just feels that way it just really
feels like you're not putting that
begrudgingly they're doing it because
there's a there's a comparison point on
the other side
and they're being successful with it
and it just doesn't feel like the same
effort is being put in the same thought
and like i said the same ideology is not
in place so it just feels weird because
what they're doing within the constructs
of this of a service doesn't doesn't
make sense um so that
so the stacking stuff yeah go ahead john
oh no i was just gonna say it's kind of
just people focus on microsoft's a
trillion dollar company sony's a billion
dollar company and they focus on the
acquisitions i think this is actually
how it shows up this is actually how it
manifests because somebody doesn't have
a trillion dollars to to show up to the
game and take these risks it's like
who's there at a blackjack table and
microsoft's just like betting on
everything you're like what are you
doing like my cards will come or cards
will come exactly nobody's making these
kind of like they're they're kind of
like inching and they're just like you
know penny penny bets and and hoping
that it kind of pays off it's just it's
not as risky
they're trying to get like yeah a little
bit of payoff here a little bit of
payoff here and and microsoft is just
all in
the show in fairness according to the
model is are we
wrong for chastising them for not being
able to play in that space
that microsoft could play in because of
the war chess like we're no definitely
not we are that's how it shows up right
in fairness to sort of i i do feel we
are asking them to act like their wallet
and their bank could do what microsoft
banks for sure
[Music]
the issue that i have isn't that they're
trying that you know they're not trying
to compete with microsoft's wallet the
issue i have is you're putting these
services in place and you're getting mad
when people are taking advantage of it
and instead of doing the right thing and
honoring that you just you you just
ripped the rug off no i i feel you but
anyways but what if
we're gonna we're gonna put the stock
hit the stop but you know the product
you gonna pay for the party it's funny
yeah i think i i think when you think
that that's the thing we always say oh
they don't have the same wallet cool
they don't
there's certain things they can eat they
could eat this
sauce
yeah they don't know what if smart
business is
monetized
so let's get into the stacking right
right let's go it's not about if they
can it's it's that when you don't have
that kind of cash you make silly
decisions right right like that's all
i'm trying to that's what i was just
saying
let me let me let up soldiers wallet but
what if we can't do that right what if
it's not that type of situation over
here
from one day to the next right you have
all of these ps plus subscriptions out
there that people could buy or don't buy
right they've been sitting there right
right you give people a reason to want
to buy them and to jump in right get get
them all off the shelf let them do let
them be in on your services
totally agree but but we're the market
leader they love us
why we got the games and they don't got
the game why do we need to do this
but this this is the short game right
the short thing is okay the dude that
when the three years is up for the dude
distract this uh stack to three years
all right
what if you haven't done anything to
keep him
right what if you haven't done the work
to keep that dude then what so why so
here come this ragnarok trailer we're
gonna get you back
not with a tree we got we got this rag
to rock we got we got this we got
trailers we're gonna be in the third
tier like we got this horizon
we tell
shout out to wario 64 because i got in
right when he said it
and i got three years stuck
you beat the person you got it before
the fans
the spartacus was out there man yeah
but they ain't gonna let you upgrade to
um put the money in the bag and when oh
it was it was fall out
real river would fall off
we're gonna have dlc we're not telling
you what it is
300 games but what it is
see they don't solve love hold on hold
on hold on what's crazy i love you at a
discount
they they had
they had a system set up
and then they openly say yo if you are a
member you'll get to the highest tier
yeah which i look i look you feel like
once that once that membership goes up i
feel like they're going to gradually
auto renew them to the eighteen dollar
tier oh there so that makes no sense why
you wouldn't automatically hold it let
me finish we got a spreadsheet for you
um
so if we convert you
at um your one month ps voucher we can
convert you to 20 days a playstation
plus extra and um with your one month we
convert you 17 days a playstation 3
hold up what happened to your good time
hold up hold up
peacemaking on the yard let me finish
let me finish so they set this system up
that's been there for years yeah they're
like look if you guys have this we'll
convert it you'll get the highest tier
you'll be popping and then like oh god
people are stacking no you can't do that
but but we don't it's like calvin's in
there yeah and he and they got people
talking to them they're like but they
don't they they're giving us money for a
promise they're not even giving us money
for content that doesn't matter stop it
stop stopping what's happening you know
freebies over here we do something new
this is the funny thing and don't don't
quote me i could have said you love us i
could have sworn that they there was
something that came out afterwards where
they adjusted like cog was saying they
adjusted the the transition rate yes so
you were getting less than you initially
were shout out to the charts either way
even if even if you got the stack
they're gonna get you some way seriously
this is so you got two years worth of
stack
okay i didn't know that so you needed to
tell me that i think they told people
they told people yo if you're gonna if
you're gonna do this we're gonna honor
it but we ain't gonna give you a hundred
percent we're not giving you one to one
no so not only is people going out there
spending sixty dollars for a year but
and not even getting the whole year and
you guys are so hard on that ain't good
enough
like that ain't good enough like we want
that extra time we want i mean if you
convert it from a whole year and you
what you feel like that's the demos
that's the demos because the demos eat
up a lot of your real life time off
so if you think about it and you said
well it was like 14 days out of the out
of the month that you get
or something like that that's what you
guys said so if it's 14 days that means
every two months they're getting one
month yeah so
no i right now if i had a fraud button
sony is frauding for this you needed to
tell me that you're not gonna do all
that
hold up you mean to tell me you're not
gonna do a hundred percent conversion
rate no they're not they're not this is
the same way
you're gonna do you you're not gonna do
a hundred percent conversion when you're
getting mad about the people trying you
literally they're paying you for half of
the subscription no they don't care
about it that's the thing they want 100
of them 100 of the money that's your
money
i'm saying that you're gonna stack these
now and if it's 14 days out of the month
that you get that means when it's
converted you're going to get half of
that year you can't get mad at sony for
one all or nothing yes
they could have alleviated this by just
stopping it before they announced it
they might have they might have
deliberately did this knowing that they
were going to pull the carpet just so
they can get those cells
look this interesting thing i just
thought this is a great topic for the
realm
look i'll jump in um yeah i was
definitely surprised by this you know um
where i'm like calling me old school
gamer but i'm from the days of the you
know oxm magazines the game pros and
stuff you know demos were my generation
for free you know saying it's a demo
it's a trial so now we're talking a
two-hour commitment not anymore yeah now
we're talking to our commitment the
question is you know
i believe there's some controversy as
far as who's actually responsible from
the development style i heard some
rumors oh no sony's doing it on the
playstation store but then i'm hearing
other things i know this is the
developer has to do it and they have a
specific window so you know we'll get
more confirmation on that aspect to me
it's like
monetizing demos in a tier optically is
a bad look like it's just it's just not
like the craziest thing i've ever done
yet
for you if you if you were number two
and number three no demo for you
but the thing i think nobody's talking
about is okay you got your service cool
right but like
who who's getting the cut
who's getting the cut of this demo that
is provided
because that's to get your game out
there to be seen
[Laughter]
like if the more i see okay we gonna
give you the game because we got the
gamers
so we're gonna give you access to our
portfolio right and then
you you get to peek in you get to see
and then they get to see your game and
then hopefully they buy you
so big oh so this is the privilege of
being on your great service
and see to me
if it comes out that it is the developer
that has to do this
like trials and demos that's resources
that's game development to take away you
want to be over here
we've heard the stories even from e3
like making a demo having something
presented you know if you're in or not
me add this to you when you're talking
like
let's say someone comes out there like
we mandated we want this you ain't on
our stuff right why not though why can't
i beat it
but there's certain developers like rock
star like certain high calibers
exactly what i was just about to say
i was about to say your point i'll see
this is where the kid in play came in
you were saying that
oh yo you know certain developers and i
was gonna say i'm walking straight in
the club right now and i'm not paying
and you like yo why homeboy ain't paying
well you said everybody got paid by
tuesday nah he different he made high
quality games that bring people two
hours they
from moving forward has to be all
developers if you to join you got to
make a game try
so what about what about the price thing
today as long as your joint is 34
dollars wholesale if you're getting 30
50 retail right if your guess 35 or more
you got to have this thing and we all
know all a games is 70 cash so you right
everybody here and here's the other
thing that no one else is talking about
we got to talk about let's be honest
like developer resources like yeah
activision 2k in them they got the
resources to really have the time to if
it becomes developer's responsibility to
make that what if you little you know
the smaller guy the double a guy right
that's resources right so you got a
service fee
have you decided that demos are good for
the game sales like is that is that a
fourth conclusion that's the thing i i
think when demos went down a good game
to the 360 right now
when demo started going down towards the
end of 360 generation
i guess there was some sort of some sort
of calculation made that the demos on
their own mm-hmm
did not move the needle that right yes
it was trailers and stuff like that
because it's quick you see it and if
there's gameplay in the trailer it's
like okay fine but actually going in and
downloading and playing a demo but
here's the things off
this is what once what i got this is a
game trial for two hours from my
understanding right right you have so
basically it's two hours of the game
think like ea play in a sense right
that's the so what if you really eat for
that two hours
as a gamer you could be like nah i'm
good
what i'm saying you could really yeah
okay guys it could be a double it could
be a double hit on devs and publishers
that like you do you have to do the
thing that you probably don't even want
to do right and also it could hurt your
sales right
and to get the slice so basically it's
two hours of the real game press start
two hours
right so if you want the customers let's
be honest i'm gonna assume a lot of devs
ain't gonna want that right it could be
either or right no but you gotta get
some demo right but you gotta get
approval from sony to be like you gonna
get a vertical custom slice of two hours
as opposed to press start two hours okay
two hours it's like i said
i don't believe this man they i they're
gonna come out there and say it we want
everyone to do it but like i said it's
like that one studio that come up there
like rockstar because if they're gonna
mandate something like that there's got
to be consequences like you know pulling
the game off the story you won't sell it
but if you come out there as like a rock
star and you like i'm coming in the club
anyway because you need my game you want
to make the million dollars
what are they going to do are they going
to say yo gta 6 ain't coming on
playstation 5
no i don't see that and then and then
once those start happening once those
start happening you got the other people
that's like yo why is he going to go in
the club why is he going to be up here
everybody
engagement storefront sony numbers
you know in store basically get that but
i i highly doubt if someone like
rockstar said we're not doing a demo you
gonna eliminate a whole platform of sony
say this is what it is
but i but here's the thing you've seen
them cave from people like fortnight a
free to play game so what what like big
enough big enough to move like fortnight
rockstar i i i guarantee you rockstar if
it came between gta 6 being default
console exclusive on xbox and this whack
rule sony is caving before rockstar does
okay
gta 5
sold like what a hundred million plus
you think sony's gonna let that money
just go look it's gonna be interesting
guys so i just think i just think we're
we're in a time where the demo as we
know it doesn't make a whole lot that
was funny yeah you heard that he said
we're in the time
demo
and imagine uh imagine imagine
developers that make short games it's
like nine hours eight hours
if you got a ten hour joint and you give
us about two hours like you're getting
well this is the thing right that's
another thing where you have to think
about like okay somebody people can
speed run elden ring in
two hours you know what i mean so it's
like
and so the 50 price point helps in that
more than likely the games that we
consider to be indie games won't be
included in that right because
a five-hour game shout out to donald
trump i think
today it's gonna be a new price point
gonna drop me 30 dollar game
i'll join this these 30 dollars
that's what's gonna end up happening
you're gonna have these indie developers
ragnarok
with their own internal studio bringing
the price down you're gonna have these
indie developers they're like oh you
were right in this dlc
i wasn't gonna say it that was messy
salute
what's funny is you're gonna have these
studios like the life of strange studios
that have like episodic type of games
and obviously they're starting to do
them more as a bundle it's like you're
going to let them play the whole first
episode
for free
doesn't it doesn't doesn't the trial
start when you start the download
imagine if these developers are like
look
you know we we we we wanted to release a
40 but do we really want them playing
our wac game for for two hours because
because i think that's going to hurt the
cells more and it's going to help like a
lot of these games a lot of these games
are false
marketed to us and then when we actually
play the game we like
damn we really just bought that
like that was gonna be we played the two
hours yo
they lied to us
safe i ain't buying it
i just think game pass is the greatest
demo disc ever and
if you're not going to do that don't do
it it's not fair all i'm saying is
encounter is just that i just think
everybody wallet is not the same
and they move to a different business
model and they're going to stick to what
works for them but they don't care about
what other people are doing because they
got the games and they're sony and until
until the base says although the base
has shown me faces shut up right now the
hardcore bases show me that there is not
[Music]
microsoft doing something in their own
company doing something microsoft can't
be doing this and that's
unconstitutional what they've been doing
someone needs to make it
someone needs to make me a meme of
thanos without those those infinity
stones thinking he got them he about to
snap it and that's that's sony and then
iron man as a rock star and they stop it
the only thing i will say is interesting
and they have to be careful this is why
i gotta give king his flowers on this is
that
this i knowing the sales thing you know
people get into the fanboy stuff but
at the reality is this
if they are microsoft is kind of pumping
from the mountains yo for the quarter we
are the number one next generation
selling whatever right and the joke is
they got no games well if if they
technically have their games which they
do but
and they're winning
the sales
margin and they haven't hit their stride
yet
you have to be careful you have to be
careful these are those moments and
we've seen it during the ps3 generation
i got to give kidneys because kings say
yo
this is i'm seeing a mistake
i'm seeing mistakes and i'm like nah
king not aiming no cataclysmic yet
and i i got a front it got me looking at
side eyes with a lot of different moves
now especially this year from gran
turismo
it just seems like there's always
some new controversy yeah they didn't do
any catastrophic don't get me wrong they
still they're still selling obviously
horizon for being what i'm saying right
there i said grab three more sales right
but it did say it was like the
grandchild was like number two whatever
but
they got to be careful because at the
end of the day if you start stockpiling
a lot of consumer mistakes and pr snafus
and things that people don't like and
reality is people can say hey no games
is that it people are buying people
still want an xbox you don't go into a
store if you don't like something
because at the end of the day you're
waiting for that quality product if the
ps5 is the quality product right and
there's no reason to get an xbox then
there should be no reason for anybody to
be buying it clearly there is value and
clearly something is driving it whether
it be game pass which it definitely
feels like it is right well i told you
what the marketing strategy was
let sony keep on marketing it and then
when you go to the store and it's not
there and you just get a pick of xbox
you know because a lot of people see the
value proposition oh does it play the
games yeah right so if it's a gift which
a lot of
these consoles are you know they come in
the gift range in prices and stuff this
is what your kid wants for uh his
birthday or your grandson or whatever
tonight call of duty that's it and
that's the questions that they ask
for tonight
and he played fortnite
king i just i just want
to see
k i just want to see a company like sony
tell activision and microsoft call of
duty's not going on our platform because
you won't give us
oh they say thank you no problem
they're going to find themselves in a
situation where not all the time but
some of the time they'll have a game
that's a demo for the top tier and in
playstation line you get two hours of
this but it's day and date on game pass
over on the other side right because
they're across platform they're gonna be
and i feel like that it just gives
another opportunity for xbox to go we'll
do that right you guys are forcing them
to do this we'll just keep picking up
day and date stuff that are gonna be and
it's that direct comparison that that's
not what they're not thinking of that
right but that's a very possible reality
it's very interesting to see just what's
up i just want i really do want sony to
like tell rockstar note i i just want
you to read it you just want to see what
happens
i want the world to burn myself they
told
fortnite i want to see if sony got are
they tall enough to tell a company like
rockstar we don't want gta 6. we're
going to see but look that's what i got
so i'm going to get these super chats
yeah
let me roll back a little bit
and i can get some merch shout out to
anonymous didn't say who they want they
got the mug they got the iop mug they
got the lords of gaming.net shirt pack
shirt gotta split a shout out in the
name we gotta get rid of that shirt yeah
no they still yeah i gotta go
i just throw the pot you gotta buy mad
backstreet no he's not kickball is that
capable it's not good for me is that
king
no no actually no no take it back this
was before this was before this is april
26th no no it was down shout out to that
questions
about to be messy but no no that was
before yeah but we want to give a shout
out to the people that we missed when we
were out there in packs so are you ready
to go
yep all right let's get this out
kay johnson member for four months
somebody told them dudes their names are
not on the list back of the line hot now
they're hitting from the outside of the
club they can't even get in jesus
nearly 800 chat y'all hit that like
button yes let's go let's get that over
400 yes please podcast
and we got tickets we'll do cartwheels
in his basement
you looking for that right there you you
don't do that
king
i told you every time you hit the like
button a new sony fan ears goes straight
to sony's ridiculous ridiculous
development houses
we got jacob j five dollar super check
king chill and that you we saw talk you
don't want to add to that wrong only two
percent of the time that you got going
ah sounds like fears in your heart
[Laughter]
you sound like the two percent that was
against acquisitions uh
i just want to point out the cyberpunk's
still not on game pass
i picked it up for 13 bucks
listen listen i can admit when i'm wrong
and it's very very very few and far
between there goes that three percent
right there so good you happy with that
you should
i'm gonna have to get a cyber player
you got super chats to read time
to play that bug snacks
[Laughter]
[Music]
playstation plus is the homeowner's
association of gaming too many rules and
regulations
are we finally going to accept that
playstation is a monopoly if i look at
the the triple a game space it's xbox
and playstation and in most of the world
playstation has over 90 percent of the
markets here playstation is definitely
leveraging their position
[Music]
monopoly should have been shot down
bessie continue
then we got rain g4 with a bunch of iop
shields thank you sir remember
then we got hargy chinny again five
dollar super chat xbox does not require
xbox live gold to play demos is that a
question mark uh not sure where that's
coming from i don't know what what is
the status with that i don't play demos
like that so the status of what
can you play demos on xbox live without
having gold
i don't know that's a good question i
i've literally never downloaded the hell
has an xbox without having online like i
don't know
what i did just with the raw district
just going up to your xbox
[Music]
hard to find two dollar super chat
somebody cut the subs with baking soda
right [ __ ]
bacon soda bacon
i got yo girl focusing advantage i'm
gonna go get that we got a new hydration
line right now you got the website in
the red white and blue they got the
little drain with split gate go get that
that focus may be focused that's why
that's why his eyes are so alert
who is that pax right addict oh yo
code iron lord on the checkout y'all
y'all know what to do
powder okay
yeah
it was delicious
it was it was so delicious that i had to
go up and i had to buy that stuff oh no
no no you're not living to your namesake
moving on
[Laughter]
let's go we got jonas the dad five
dollars in the chat emperor nadella king
phil todd the god the worm has totally
turned that is true
good
then we got doughnut taco two dollars of
a chat that new triple that new double a
price about to be 33.99
then we got chris mccomb two pounds
super chat phil needs to make a video
with free demos on xbox
then we got smelly wrestling geek
so does game pass help game sales or
hurt game sales since demos didn't move
the needle
wow shout out to the wrestling geek
smelly one
not the normal one the smelly ones this
is hollywood
shout out to him there we go
free can't even contain himself so
jealous when people come up with awesome
names like that
oh my god so good so good we have a thx
1138 five dollars we'll be checking
gotta watch ragnarok dlc with the
two-hour trial it's 50 of the game
yo ice cold you ain't gonna do me that
talk about i got steroids you just stop
ridiculous continue each muscle group
that's it
we're caught up we'll cut up we're gonna
all right let's go let's go
we're moving
i do want to make an announcement real
quick
people uh
um
this tuesday or wednesday i i keep
getting the days mixed up uh the attic
show king and
hip hop gamer oh
[Music]
so y'all heard the attic show when the
attic show dropped what is that
5 p.m on wednesday oh wait wait king
david and hip-hop gamer oh
go that give me the logo too
same here on that channel
king kong versus godzilla salute to
hip-hop there salute to hip-hop you
already know anyway let's get into it
yeah um shout out to imran khan you know
what i'm saying news editor at fan fight
media and former senior editor of game
informant you put out a little salacious
tweet so it looks like um yeah they
couldn't look wb man wb games out here
they said that he couldn't get enough
confirmation to actually write a post
yet but hearing a decent bit of chatter
this week about wb discovery shopping
their game development studios around
interested parties include ea take two
microsoft sony tencent netease and pub g
corp uh wbd wants to sell studios and
license ip supposedly so solve this was
in place if you're talking about the
show up your head i know you wanted to
potentially talk about another thing as
well in terms of microsoft activation so
flow is yours what you want to do
yeah let's go with this first um
so yeah this is interesting because uh
you know the the merger between
discovery and warner media finished like
at the start of this month well it's may
already so at the start of april um and
then they're now warner brothers
discovery
um and we were wondering what was going
to happen because i you know towards the
the end of sort of before this deal
coming together
warner brothers sort of pulled back that
desire to sort of
to sell to sell off their studios but
at the time we thought that suicide
squad maybe harry potter maybe uh gotham
knights was sort of eminent so it sort
of made sense for them to hold on to
those properties they saw that bill
that's what they saw they saw that bill
how much is yeah so i it felt like those
games were eminent and obviously you
know things get delayed and
you know we're not going to see suicide
squad until next year harry potter
possibly this year and of course gotham
knights possibly this year so um
yeah so it's interesting to me that now
that everything is under one umbrella
they're like yeah we want to divest
ourselves of this stuff and get rid of
these news
because they don't bring in money
quickly the way we would want them to
you know game development is hard and
you know google figured it out like
there's it's a lot of stuff that
you have to be
in it for the long haul and be willing
to take the ups and downs to see the
rewards and
maybe they don't want to do that so
what's interesting is that uh shout out
to amron he said that at some of the
interested parties in purchasing some of
these studios and purchasing some of the
well the studios
apparently the word is that the studios
would come along with
contracts that would extend sort of uh
the use of the properties but not the
ownership of the properties necessarily
so um yeah some of the interested
parties were ea take two of the big ones
microsoft sony tencent netease
um
so he's it says here wants to sell
studios and license and license vip not
sell the items it's huge which is huge
um
so what do you guys think we've talked
about this ad nauseam a number of times
and speculation of you know what
microsoft needs what could sony possibly
want out of this
um my thoughts on it are this um
these studios
are talented studios up there on the
court
and these
the licensing for some of these
properties is going to be through the
roof
so it's going to be it's going to be
it's going to be interesting what these
companies whoever's buying
wants to do with these properties as
opposed to just grabbing a studio
and
putting them on something brand new i
don't even know if the terms of sale
would would would be that you have to
take a license i don't know how that
works right so um that could be a
possibility as well so again we've
talked about this in a number of
different ways what do you guys see
possibly coming out of this and how soon
do you possibly think we could hear
something of a rumblings of an actual
sale of studios going on
which didn't show
well i'm wondering what the sort of
timeline is on the whole activision
thing are we like basically expecting
that microsoft cannot or will not make
any new moves
until that closes like yeah which you
feel like you can't have to settle on
that so like if you allow for yeah they
can keep buying up stuff in the next
year then i could see this happening
quite soon if they're quite open to this
and same thing with ubisoft right but do
they now have they blocked themselves
from any future big acquisitions until
whatever june 2023 next year it's a good
question because we had a shout out to
hoge law or the virgin gang shout out to
big casting it was just one there you
know we had him and he was breaking this
down and i asked because he he's a
corporate you know lawyer for mergers
and acquisitions he deals a lot of this
stuff specifically not just the youtube
pundits not just a youtube pundit
not just a spicy tate guy
he says if i come on is that that term
gonna be used i was like only if you use
it but i i didn't know sean was coming
on dude no you're good you're good but
now he did say that um i asked him
directly that question la shawn and i
said you know what is that going to
preclude them is that going to stop them
because you know quote-unquote all the
eyes are on them right of the thing now
he said he probably didn't see anything
like a publisher level but he said that
would not stop them from an individual
studio that he said he could still see
that and i'm like this year even with
all the you know the attention he said
yeah it's impossible it's definitely a
possibility he doesn't see that stopping
them but yes uh publisher level big
thing maybe not so much because of the
activision situation
yeah so i mean i could see them still
obviously they're obviously interested
they're listed in this group so maybe
that's the answer right there i don't
need to complicate it any more than that
i am with king on one thing i will give
him credit on this this like
i don't like when
playstation has a thing and then
everybody who goes well xbox needs the
playstation thing like that seems almost
like it's almost boring honestly like
they need their they're uncharted they
need their whatever else their god of
war um they need their spider-man i
honestly can they do something else so i
get that i get that perspective um but
this would be really exciting
on both sides if they got the ip it's
obvious batman those batman games just
reignited and resurrected the superhero
genre as we know it it's why we have
spider-man that's why we have these
games
i believe i think so i think before
arkham asylum like what what did we have
so people wanted that was cool so people
wanted those and like those games
they're the hero games that where they
think
xbox at one point well i just want to
just be clear because you know
it was pretty lame before until
spider-man came and changed
yeah batman but i like spiderman a
little bit more accessible but then
there's the flip side of this whole does
it come with ip does not come with ibm
obviously if it comes with it very cool
if it doesn't i think people are
discrediting one thing in that when you
buy
um publisher like activision
blizzard and you've got rare at the helm
still you've got all these other um ip
is really what i'm getting at you've got
a just a huge warehouse
of ideas and you don't have enough
studios to tackle them all so i think
the wb thing could be yeah you got like
a rock star and they can't make a batman
game anymore
that sucks but they could also make all
these other games you get any of these
people on um i don't even know like any
of the old rare stuff or any of the old
activision things that are just like
laying there
waiting to get to get a developer aside
to it so i think there could be some
value in that like just
getting some talent to deal with this
this warehouse of ip that they've got is
probably the number one
reason why i would say they could go
after these these sets of developers i
think not fair yeah fair enough lord
addict
where you're at wb is supposedly outside
look it
i mean i
i don't think sony would buy something
like this um
i think if something buys something
likes it would be like a 10 cent or
something that is still going to be
third party now i could see
i do feel like if microsoft's able to
they need to secure another realm like
you know i know people want you know uh
rocksteady for like the hero stuff and
that would be nice but i feel like i'm
with you they
i feel like if they want rocksteady but
i do feel like they need netherrack
even if they don't get the mortal kombat
franchise which i feel like they they
need to try to get that but even if they
don't get that they desperately need
someone for killer instincts and i feel
like there's
because they lost evo yeah well not
necessarily lost evil but their
competition bought evo
uh they're most likely not going to get
street fighter or at lea at the very
least there's going to be exclusive
content on street fighter
they need something to have
a relevancy when it comes to the
head-to-head fighter market i don't care
about that market like they could
literally let this market die and it
wouldn't bother me
i do understand that there's a lot of
people that like this genre and there's
a lot of people that like killer
instinct and
if they're able to get mortal kombat the
best way they can do it is okay we
bought another round we have more combat
we're going to do a more combat versus
killer instinct and then a couple years
after that do a killer instinct game by
itself and then do more combat game by
itself and then do another one of them
together uh it's just i feel like it's
it's the one that makes the most sense
now if they could get rocksteady and
netherrealm that'd be the perfect dream
uh because i just don't think
buying the whole company is on the table
for almost anyone i mean
tents is the only person i could really
see doing that sure sony could buy a
couple studios or even potentially the
whole the whole bundle but i don't think
that makes sense from what sony's doing
because i felt like
right now they're they they haven't
established third person market they
don't really need to double down on that
market and you see them doing a bungee
where they're trying to get more of a of
a of a presence in like the free-to-play
market the games as a service market
that's where i feel like they're trying
to build up that i don't really
necessarily see
sony building more onto something that
they already have pretty much have a
monopoly on yeah not fair enough
can
your thoughts here on wb and whether
they should acquire individual studios
or
not
should they be involved
um
no
wow
not at all they they should uh only pick
up publishers
uh
studios
oh they should just buy the building oh
yeah yeah
um again
do you think
do you think after they buy activision
do you think the government would let
them buy another big publisher like yeah
yourself um
[Music]
what's gonna happen and you're gonna
look over at me and be like i don't know
what you're drinking but
you write always
um
boy this is so it's kind of irritating
it's kind of irritating
and let me say let me i'm gonna tell you
why it's irritating
they have absolutely nothing to offer
sony so sony's not looking at any of
them right so
no
sony's trying to make games of a service
mm-hmm none of these guys are making
games for the surface stuff for that
gotham knights thing and we don't know
really
what it all entails until you know at
the end when actually releasing what is
the most dominant head-to-head fighter
i don't know i don't play well
that's a good question you know
everybody keeps looking at the head of
the head fighter thing
probably i think that i think
i think that that nether realm is
probably the the the best the only thing
they have there sony's not going to do
that
10 cent will go and put money
wherever
in in in the developers
and don't want to own a majority share
so i don't see 10 cent doing that i can
see amazon
on netflix picking up wb developers and
and licensing them out to make uh
certain games uh for them uh i think
they're in that stage where uh stadia
was picking up uh developers like iron
studios and stuff like that to make
games or what was that amazon that did
that
um
netflix and amazon looks like the the
better fit for uh wb uh developers
people that are looking to acquire
studios and make games
microsoft is in a position they're
looking for publishers they're looking
for
the the you know how to practice that
game distribute the game make the games
we just want to give you uh oversight
and direction on what we're looking for
and if you fit in our portfolio i don't
see wb fitting in that their portfolio i
think i think they already have two
publishers that could take care of that
for the rest of the developers they
bring on i do feel like if they buy a
studio or two king they could easily
have the other publishers run those
studios
yeah but
you have to look at the the rewards see
you you can see all the reward in
bethesda you can see all the reward and
activision
never realms only fits a certain niche
for a certain demographic
demographic to something like game pass
to keep these people in that service not
if you're getting third-party deals
if you're getting third-party
they have a ton of fighters inside there
like i believe i believe
it's uh yeah and um
but those those those those those are
not considered fighters
not in game pass now i'm talking about
um well yes it is yeah nano justice now
what you want injustice and injustice
yeah interesting my bad
games double checking my back yeah and
in certain fighting games that you won't
consider a fighting game but no i
consider it a
no um certain games
but
again i don't consider anything a
fighting game i don't care i'm just
putting that out there
those two games that we was playing
those are fighting games but the dragon
ball z games that's just me beating you
games
um those games are there
i just i i'm sorry i don't see the magic
i don't see the lore i see capcom really
can actually go to sony i think their
whole portfolio fits uh sony's branding
um
i i can see that
sega after seeing certain things and i
uh saw the sonic 2 movie it was dope um
i could see sega fitting with microsoft
or the the the publishing arm of them so
you
i just don't i don't know wb just
doesn't it doesn't hit those boxes that
microsoft needs to be checked
and it just doesn't fit for me i feel
like the initiative is a big box that
they need to check off it's a big
problem for them and this it speaks to
the talent that they need to bring on i
don't think that has worked out the way
they plan crystal dynamics is doing a
wonderful job i have absolutely no idea
we'll see i feel like we'll see i
actually i actually personally feel like
wb
fills more boxes than ubisoft
you think so because you got the you got
the studio that can make some type of
hero game because that is one of the
things they don't have
you got to
distribute
across the world
they're publishing their own stuff now
aren't they does it say on the box
published by wb
but the distribution arm once they're
cut off from discover
see so
looking at the distribution arm when it
was with a t and t and a t and t was the
distribution arm
they they're no longer attached to that
so they're just a developer just sitting
there with their arms folded we got a
game but we don't know how to move this
product but they can't move they ain't
got a pipeline so that's what big
microsoft for right now microsoft don't
want that product they already get
we got a guest in the round with a spicy
camera is that gaming forte of the dps
podcast podcast what's going on sir
what's going on man how you guys in here
doing y'all being a little hot today
what's going on this is what i'm talking
about
is that man look man a lot of topics you
know so
there is a publishing unit called warner
brothers games
okay
are they up for sale
oh my god okay so so we're gonna go all
the way up for sale oh do they have to
purchase
another are you gonna let me speak
boxing nuggets so you gotta buy each
nugget so so we gonna so did we
automatically assume they bought
bethesda was their publishing unit up
for sale everything went they went and
brought the building they're buying
warner brother games they buying water
brother games
[Music]
yo she not interested
she just don't want it you know it's the
same way with platinum games they don't
want them
so they could be added
that's not true with wb games they all
rumors that they kicked the tires on
they went over there they looked like
what's in the box right
discovery said oh by the way you don't
got to buy the whole thing we got them
on the individual levels
the rumors were that they wanted the ips
and that's why the deal
let me get this
the person he's saying is not interested
is literally implicated
do i get the extra cheese on there yeah
they said okay
yeah well we wasn't selling it with
extra cheese but now we got extra cheese
on it yeah what do you want what you
expect
you said you don't want it but your bed
got photoshopped in 4k in the dms
they can't be with you if you were
saying yo they don't need the whole the
whole fridge i get we might need the
milk in the fridge you know
what that meant we got gabriel forte in
the buildings bro what do you think wb
there's the rumors are out there we got
the interested parties including
microsoft
what do you think sir oh it's gonna
happen
or do you agree with kate like there's
not value here and he's like you know
microsoft specifically shouldn't even
look at that uh no it's definitely value
there it just really comes down to
exactly what parts of it they want
because i do think that it's not going
to be one entity that's going to buy the
entire thing i do think it's going to
get split up amongst different uh places
and stuff because i think that's how
they're going to maximize how much they
get for the publisher
overall
you know individual publishers selling
for more especially if you talk about
when it comes to um
what's the name of the studio that did
um
the um
the shadow of war games oh monolith
yeah yeah especially with monolith you
get you get access to their um
every that yeah the decimal that's the
yeah the nemesis
this is this is all he wants
to know
did i not say all they need is
netherrealm from that studio like
nothing else no no you said now but you
love the nemesis scissors
i'm all about the name
yes
yes
you've been sliding in those deals for a
minute
they keep ignoring me they keep leaving
i know shout out to monolith shout out
to my king definitely but again i'm
sorry that's the biggest thing that i
think that's going to really come from
because i do agree out of all the
acquisition well all of those studios
like the another realm is the one that
xbox really should go after uh because i
think it shores up with something that
they really don't have and i mean when
it comes to like their killer instinct
franchise that's like the only real uh
fight game that's the only genre they're
missing it's only genre they're missing
and then you literally bring by far the
biggest one back into the ecosystem
which at this point it seems like it's
even bigger than street fighter and
stuff at this point
so you bring that into house and then
like i said if you do want to go
engine wise and when it comes to
development side go after monolith for
something like the nemeziz engine where
you can introduce that into a bunch of
your different games not just their
games online that would be very
beneficial too so i do think that there
are pieces that are available that would
be good for microsoft to go after or
anybody to go out there but i do think
as a whole
you're not going to see the whole thing
just go to one person especially since
they came out and said the ips are on
the table right and
i think i got one more thing yeah please
as is tradition
[Laughter]
but yeah look i i know keig is strong
with this and i i do understand where
he's going i don't i know we disagree on
this one but i do understand this point
king wants publisher arms i understand
some of them some of it
was his engines
and to his point from a management
perspective it makes it easier for xbox
game studios so they don't have to do as
much micromanaging i do think like i
said the interest is there i would add
it 100 on the fact that i think
netherrealm actually even though i'm
hashtag just one i think another realm
is to play you know i mean even if you
that you can't get mortal kombat
exclusive having it in game pass similar
to a call of duty situation i think it's
super attractive and i think they'll be
able to get more to come but again the
reason why you need like i said you if
you would need that is that you want
game pass diversity you want those
different level of titles titles to hit
different markets in the service that
you're trying to promote you need that
so i love that aspect i'm actually cool
don't travel his tail now because i
would i wanted before i went at rock
steady bottom left the whole thing right
but
now that you got the activation what is
it toys for bob and
like you kind of don't need the family
as much you got king you got like you
activision kind of helped that
kick through you know so it's like they
kind of they don't really have the
family thing
like you know plug anymore like
deficiency as much so but yeah i'm with
the fighting game of course with hashtag
just one of course i'm with saw for my
the arkham series and all that greatness
and i think the thing was they were
attractive with with the ip without the
ip when they were trying to say like
that you get it just the studio you know
with no i'd be like giving that
chicken nuggets yeah no no sweet sour
sauce like no seasoning
just kidding
just ketchup
we ain't consulting anybody from wb
exactly you know so that's all i got but
it's interesting
don't you think king that phil is is
spiteful enough or he would take the
opportunity to buy mortal kombat have
them make that game so that sony can put
it as their their main event at evo like
don't you think that that's a thing
no
i think that would be hilarious
it'd be like that like the mlb the show
like we're gonna get mlb on game pass
we're gonna buy this game it's gonna be
on right there exactly that's why i
asked him to king that's i'm surprised
at this
i think when
capcom was having the issues um before
the resurgence
that was a bigger play to do that and as
that's a bigger kick them in the chest
with what they did with the street
fighter 5. should we find out franchise
um
i think he's beyond petty like he said
he sees past them and and he's he's he's
just trying to be malevolent to the
point where the ultimate level of petty
is the forcing of x uh game pass on the
box right um
so
now i i
i just i
as much as i want to see that happen
as much as i would love to see certain
things happen it's just been so many
barriers so many years you just don't
see it happening
because they had opportunities at a
cheaper price and i know everybody's
saying but king is the licensee issues
okay so now that's not the issues no
more now
uh
the battery has been removed they can
actually purchase the licensee right
does it fit in the corners because we
don't know what they got in the
background what they're making in the
background
yeah we don't know what studios actually
stepped up and because we we we saw a
die by the blade
by a small studio that put together a
phenomenal game that is very responsive
in a different um
a way and feel of a fighting game and it
brought
back the feeling of fight and the
adrenaline is there right
we don't know if one of those studios
actually has stepped out the box and
developed the game in the same ilk
we don't know that you don't need
another realm
on the pedigree right and then if i if
i'm going if you're going to say that
then you can look over at kojima kojima
has a pedigree you know there's other
high profile people out there that i
would go for a whole lot faster to have
a different pedigree that fits a better
build uh for your uh for your brand this
is mine let's see let's see what happens
no doubt solving some chat's last topic
then we wrote after that
i'm sorry oh you got the super chat's
ready lined up sir one second he said
you're not prepared
all right
what the hell
are you good
a lot of people to chat everybody okay
people people in agreement 740 something
let's hit the like button
740 something real people save the
children
shout out to that chat that moves at um
more than 10 miles a second
[Laughter]
because microsoft is buying activision
doesn't mean they can't be talking yes
they're talking they're talking about do
you have slidin
hey boo
hey guys i just noticed the pick of
miles and colt eastward with greeny yes
are they recording an xbox event imagine
a week of 90 minutes each day of xbox
games
you got to remember this is about the
same time that paris paris went out the
year before
what's happening at the same time i i
actually i i hope i hope he does hold
something dude
like always will be part of that show
kobe going hard on twitter let go hopes
up please yeah
shout out to boss don't be yeah
the next year
the next year we gotta get caught up in
that so
that's only that's all the time
i'll be happy to just be
in the in the running
if it happens saluted sir you'll be
there yeah let's see
then we got donald tackle 10 super chat
xbox has such a diverse lineup of games
compared to playstation but people keep
asking them to make the two genres
they're missing for now but they don't
put that same energy on playstation no
we do we do
this i keep making this argument it's
just the fact is when you look the
playstation brand since the start of the
playstation 4 generation
lives and dies by that third-person
over-the-shoulder cinematic action game
the quality of the playstation brand
rests on that
since then since then they're not the
playstation of old where they were weird
and had every other type of genre under
something they're not that right
they're this now yeah so if this is what
brings you number one
let's let's make something that shows
hey we can do that that's it
i'm gonna say make all the games like
that hashtag this one
99 rootkin five dollars for chat if
microsoft gets netherrealm with ip model
combat right there's three games mortal
kombat killer instinct and an xbox smash
brothers style game once i actually
think it is done
i actually think that if something like
that happens they they need to make
their own super smash brothers game with
like and i would even go as far as
hire x super smash for the devs to make
the dance
go get the talent
yeah if it ain't broke don't fix it
necromancer's there
yeah
why buy the cow when you get the milk
for free
don't make no sense let's go necromancer
sale 10
wb has good studios however with the way
everyone talks about them their worth is
only in the ip without the ip you have
to rebuild the wb studios brand there's
a lot of time and money involved yeah i
think you have to remove it from the wb
studios name at the same time those
studios
are very good studios you know they can
make action games you know they can make
fighters it's just a matter of where do
you put them without those ip
yep
the brightest sun five pound super chat
microsoft will buy uh nrs whatever it
takes do netherrealm studios whatever it
takes due to the relationship between
matt booty ed boone and midway
also microsoft hired a lot of wb execs
recently
we'll see we'll see interesting ones
that they come at it once that they
bought them a long time ago oh yeah it's
already done i was gonna see king's
reaction
they're gonna see my reaction y'all
gonna be like man the king is always
right man
what happened amazon purchased them
i just can't wait to see like the neo
matrix backflip king would do for that
situation i told you it could happen
you get somebody to commit i never said
it was never going to happen
showing up it ain't happening
kickstarted
i think my face would be pretty clean
continue
continue so that's right then we got a
bruno ramos diaz with uh yeah it
definitely was never announced yeah yeah
you would definitely put outside 20 28
brazilian reals
we got king king the witcher 2 was
published by wb games or not i don't
know i guess i guess i have no idea but
um i purchased it and i didn't care
the best part about it you ain't getting
wb on camera
so this is how microsoft show you how
you not stacking no w continue continue
raiden blade 2000 oh my god a bugs bunny
and sammy sam game road runner
wow
the possibilities are endless
apollo cooper two dollars if it's at a
spawn game with netherrealm would be so
dope it'd be crazy right
[Laughter]
crush your dreams
and you you know what's funny when i if
they bought the um king would be the
first person to play when that mortal
kombat i'm staying dead
whatever hit game pass i'm playing bug
snacks get over my back
you want to play yourself
yeah you want to play spawn get a ps
wow great small game you got a ps1 for
you okay
for the legend 5
xbox these wb honestly having mortal
kombat under their belt would be huge
and injustice as well
that'd be insane right not happening
it'll be wild
there we go bruno ramos diaz again the
11th royale
we want netherrealm
[Laughter]
in this chat
fear on xbox would be great
i got it back compact donald taco said
that you skipped my ten dollar super
chat
where i see this oh man something's
gotta jump yeah okay we'll figure it out
after getting out of the job yeah
put it in here
i got i got it okay
from dollar wb's talent doesn't lie in
the ip it's a bonus their combat systems
can work on any ip and we've seen it
with mad max shadow legos etc man
if you did a new ip with the same
gameplay it would be a hit i actually
agree with them
they know how to make gameplay they know
how to make game play i can't wait for
that to happen
[Laughter]
the amount of hate that you're doing is
just crazy just know that everybody's
sitting here wbw oh they purchased
capcom
continues
ladies saying two dollars will be chat
700 plus people here hit the like button
it is
then we got max arthy five pound super
chat tt games has some real nice synergy
for marketing with the game pass family
plan
them and netherrealm are my two picks
from the bunch no doubt like that we
already know what king gonna say move on
tech money
shut up we got a two dollar trooper
after check money wb published hitman 3
and cyberpunk is awesome
if you feel like king was completely
wrong on the publishing arm put a one in
the chat
isn't it is it hitman 3 game pass now
see so nether realms is going to come
with the wb publishing on
[Music]
go to two joel went joel is the only two
and he keep putting them
they try to even the odds
play all flavors in there
okay we got a few but the water oh
well against you oh that's crazy
yeah you already know
i know you there's an option in the car
it's an option in the car you do not get
the package with navigation unless you
pay for it why does zeon put a three
we're gonna move on but anyway
yeah i don't know what's going on with
that assignment yeah shout out to
flame the last one then we gotta go on
two dollars yeah
flame don't look me in like and you know
what wb games is a waste of jesus look i
went ahead and i did what i do best
we're going through all the polls that
he wants all y'all to go for
100 percent the wrong way yeah it's the
last topic this is king's topic i will
set him up
ps5 veil variable refresh rate support
is rolling out has rolled out this week
and shout out to the playstation blog
who put it up today we're excited to
announce the vrr support will be rolling
out to ps5 players on hdmi 2.1 vrr
compatible tvs and monitors it
dynamically syncs the refresh rate of
the display to the five ps5 console's
graphical output enhances visual
performance minimizing eliminating
virtual awkward fun effects such as
frame pacing screen tearing gameplay and
many ps5 titles feel smoother as scenes
render seamlessly graphics look crisper
and input lag is reduced so they got
that they said in the coming weeks uh
ps5 versions of these titles will
receive game patches enabling vrr
support astral's playroom call of duty
vanguard black ops cold war death loop
destiny 2 devil may cry 5 dirt 5 god 4
spider-man remastered spider-man michael
morales ratchet and clank residue
village tiny tinas wonderlands tom
clancy's rainbow six and tribes of
medgar these are just a few of the ps5
titles receiving vrr support and we'd
like to thank their talented development
teams please stay tuned to the channel
so this is king's topic it's it's i mean
every playstation top is kings it's
kicking style just for the record so i
thought vrr was just a buzzword uh for
developers that are lazy that didn't
program their games well right was they
just saying that on xbox out of vrr
isn't working and uh playstation games
is outpacing them mm-hmm now they got
vrr they got their hands in the air yeah
we get vr orders
it's gonna be dope our games are gonna
be smoother the world is going to be
prettier why
when y'all catch up to the race it's
dope then
we are always dope when we had it and
then now all of a sudden it was not that
good if he already got his whack is
useless it's not good for anything when
you don't have something it's wack and
it's trash but as soon as it's available
in your store yo it's the best thing
since
vrr was the best i knew
vrr was the wave when they said that it
was coming to playstation to the vrr
i have some information that you might
find
tell me exactly what it does when they
enable vrr
a shout out
let's roll the tape shout out to alex
battaglia of digital foundry who um
actually has some comments about uh ps5
implementation he said not everything
seems to be going well in a twitter post
he seems the vr on ps5 isn't as robust
as on xbox specifying that he's in
possession of a possession of a samsung
nu 8000 tv he said my display doesn't
seem supported at the moment he said
although it's theoretically part of the
vr compatible tvs and monitor lists he
said it's not he's not clear why does it
display vrr correctly despite the
compatibility and he said using free
sleek ultimate the ps5 recognizes
display has support but any vr content
leads to a black screen or fails now it
remains to be seen he said okay as some
similar problems also occur with other
televisions and monitors in the list and
uh pretty much he said for the moment we
remember which are the vr compatible
games so it looks like there's some
issues with the implementation yeah
that's what happens
when you tack stuff on and something see
the the xbox was built with this in mind
this is an afterthought it's like
putting a fin on the back of your car
and then you're driving down the block
you got wind drag your cars
[Laughter]
your car wasn't built for this
why now you want vrr
he's making your stuff look whack
you was capping with vr and it's hit you
hard
you're not built for this man take that
off your box
vrr was not inside the deck it was not
in the toolbox so please take the vrr
out of the box just keep doing it how
y'all y'all doing it decent just leave
your journey on please don't do not
enable that button do not hit your
neighbor
spoiler in the back i'm done with this
man
anyway um any uh let's get let's get one
of our forte on this because i'm curious
he's a vrr guy he's a monitor tech guy
how you feeling about ps5 or vr
implementation on the announcement
man why is everything so late on this
system was this system supposed to come
out all the time
all these features that keep get we're
still waiting for 1440p
to be enough you know shout out to the
1440p monitor behind me that you know
has 4k downscaling so i can actually
play my ps5 on it if i want to but it's
just you know it's cool it's something
that's been there available on multiple
platforms for the longest it's not like
it's new or anything it's not new
technology
um it's been a lot of stuff that they
just had to work their way through so
it's not a really big deal yeah i'm
happy for the people that's going to get
a chance to uh finally experience what
it is and people keep saying like oh
it's not really overvr it's not all that
it's like wait till you actually see it
wait till you get a chance to play
something in vegas
it's just like when people was like you
know five or ten years ago like 10 years
ago oh man 60 frames per second ain't
all that i like playing call of duty at
30 and playing halo at 30 frames per
second it didn't look at him now oh my
god 60 series is the holy grail so it's
like you know a lot of people just have
different crazy viewpoints so this type
of stuff until they actually get a
chance to experience it so once sony
does implement this and they get it into
a wide breadth of games that they have
releasing i think it's going to be a lot
better and i even think it's going to
even be better in their first party
games because that's the one place i
think not only is it going to benefit
them when it comes to
just smoothing out the animations and
making their uh frame rates a little bit
even more palatable i do think they'll
be able to push the envelope a little
bit higher when it comes to the uh
fidelity their games too because if you
can push them higher and vr smooths out
the rest of your uh performance then you
can get a better experience in your game
too so i do think overall it's going to
be a benefit it just people need to stop
copying and they can see like before
just because another platform for a
whole another year had it and we don't
have it it sucks
i just got a question um
because he said that his samsung didn't
work with it and he was getting like a
black screen do you think this is only
for the tcl users
[Laughter]
yo talk about the people that couldn't
go out they want to get a c1 or a cx hey
man hey listen man you know there's
there's only one you
[Music]
short capri are you interested this
whole vrr thing it's like hey don't care
about it
it's kind of it's kind of like that it
is just strange the the to forte's point
i think like the priority of it just
being so low i think is a little bit
strange on such a premium product like
why wasn't this day one is like my big
question but i don't i don't think
that's indicative of really much more
than that they just had other priorities
yeah um but yeah like it's i think to
downplay it is also silly i think if you
do experience this it it does make a
difference where i kind of get caught up
as a gamer i think about like
i hate going is this game going to check
the box for vrr yes no for this one yes
for this one like i get like i got too
busy to be checking for this kind of
stuff we all are but we all like we all
just like i don't want another
spreadsheet to go on like what features
are here and there so i just want to
just want it taken care of and that's
sounds so fanboyish to say but like i
don't have to worry about anything like
this on xbox like vrr is there my cloud
saves work i don't have to worry about
like uploading or downloading stuff over
here it's just so much easier on that so
i don't know at what point do these
things start to add up and make a
difference but yeah it's it is strange
the only other thing on the other side
that i would say is that
it's kind of like hd back in the 360
days like how many people really have
these these tvs and it's not to say it
doesn't matter but the number of people
that it impacts i could see that's why
sony prioritized it in the way that they
did it
it's a premium system but like how many
people have a tv that can actually do
this maybe not so many not not going to
raise too much of a stink
but do you end up when you're kind of
releasing this feature in early access
that that it should be polished at this
point i think i think we can all agree
on that it's not a not a fanboy thing at
all to say it should just it should just
work so to have it come out and like
yeah it's here and
it's not all that great like why even
why even bother i don't know that
anybody was breaking down the doors for
it yeah that's fair point about valid
points i see where you're coming from on
that look it's like 8k on a box for a
system that does it
there
made a good point on that you know the
fact that playstation
um didn't prioritize that it does mean
it wasn't as a high priority setup but
it isn't a lot of people out there that
have tvs like that they have ak on the
box but the people who do bought it
though like even to my own counterpoint
like the people who do have vr like they
were the ones who bought like they're
the first people to buy
new consoles they're the ones with the
latest tech it's not grandma buying a
playstation on day one
well there's a reason that microsoft
partnered with samsung
when they released their systems
you know it's the reason they did that
because they know
there's a there's an inherent uptick in
tv purchases when people buy brand new
consoles
and a lot of people went out and did
that as soon as these ps5s and stuff
came out it was the fact that people
were super upset that they couldn't even
think about it people were trying to get
monitors that had 2.1 um hdmi ports on
them and those didn't come up for a
whole year that was a real problem and
stuff so people always are looking for
the next thing to go with the next good
thing that they have they want those
things to complement each other when i
buy brand new when i bought my xbox
series x i bought brand new headphones
bought these for my ps5
it's just a normal thing you know you
always want something shiny and new when
you do it just like everything else
especially if you're buying on day one
if you're that early adopter like you're
so the price sensitivity just isn't
there you'll spend all the money you'll
even get it from a scalper if you want
to you'll spend 800 on the thing and
then all the other stuff i totally agree
unfortunately that's not me like i i
mean don't worry
what 80 of the boxes anyway so it's fine
it's all about i think 110
80 80 i think all of them well only 13
finished the game so you got to say it
at least
is a large percentage i would say
ridiculous justification
yeah yeah he's ridiculous it's just
crazy reads right
just for clarity for uh lord short capri
lord game forte i forgot in them often
in the actual post they said as an added
option you can choose to apply because
people are saying like it's across the
board on a platform level right as
opposed to um i don't know xbox whatever
so they were saying that um you could
choose to apply vr to ps5 games that
don't support it this feature may
improve video quality for some games if
this if the results are unexpected
visual effects you can turn off this
option at any time
so if your system starts smoking it's
your part
please note that results may vary
depending on the tv you're using the
game you're playing and the visual mode
you selected for a particular game and
then they got more details on vrr
settings and a resolution guide and all
that stuff but i just want to be clear
that it can be turned on
on a
doesn't platform like auto detect like
does it have a game mode so i'm gonna be
there i'm gonna just gonna make the
settings all happen there i just i
appreciate the settings but like there's
all all the sorts of stuff what's the
the the um protection the edit or htc's
get rid of that i can't believe three
playstations with that though
gracious lord i just want i want anybody
that's gonna stream when they hit the go
button live on the vrr just stream that
for me just stream it exactly and i want
to see what happens
just hit the go live button and let's
see if it happens like what's up lord
addict lord of tech vr tvs and all this
great stuff your favorite tech topic
yeah
did you use to play video games that you
like to play no
when it comes to this cool playstation
it's like what we're almost a year
into the well we're for more than a year
and a half year and a half yeah we year
and a half now they decided to catch up
to 2022 standards like it's just like
look like you know
if people wouldn't have vocalized their
want for this feature you wouldn't have
got it like never settle for what the
competition's doing but your platform's
not doing because both of them could
easily be doing it but if you act like
you don't want it they're not going to
give it to you and this is one of those
things where i didn't care i mean you
got a people like carl king solve but
thank them for this because if it was up
to me i wouldn't care like you don't
hear one
live on that button
i don't care what you say
my playstation makes noise my
playstation i turned around innocent and
they told me to be quiet it is not quiet
at all that xbox don't make no noise
that playstation turn on my dog looking
around like what is this house making
all that noise that's that that's the
playstation so no no no and i turn on
that vro i might start a fire oh my god
here we go
please stream there we go
but at that point king you could save on
so that you could save on the the
heating bill man this is that's wrong
and one up downstairs
you know what you might be awesome you
know what instead of buying like a
boiler or anything like that just like
three of them put a raw garden
vr is great but the thing about it is
like both of these console manufacturers
when they came out there was a lot of
buzzwords a lot of talk like forte said
8k was on the box of that playstation
fastest ssd in the world yeah i was like
um
this console is not gonna it's not gonna
whiff 8k like ever and so it's just one
of those things like they like using the
buzzwords to sell the product and that's
fine but the product the buzzwords have
actually have to actually you know be
valid and work and for me you know vr
again it's
it's kind of a work in progress the same
way like when i look at hdr when you
look at hdr there's no hdr standard like
across the board there's no hdr standard
dolby vision in games looks like
dogs
yeah
so
um there's just no standards yet so
again it's a growing process and i like
the fact that both consoles are finally
getting to the point where they're gonna
grow with it right but uh yeah i mean
again none of this stuff necessarily
works as advertised there's always going
to be a compromise made with vr actually
you're going to you're going to see some
artifacting in some places you're going
to see some things not working well i
think it's funny on the playstation side
that it's just like the vr is just like
boost mode for the ps4 like for the pro
the pro i was like let me turn this
boost board and see what happens and
like it'll break certain things and
certain things
so i mean i'm glad it's there again i
just i want that parody so that you're
moving forward with the tech evolving as
opposed to just trying to catch up so i
mean that's it again but there's there's
plenty of stuff with with all these uh
bells and whistles that we expect out of
these tvs and these con these consoles
that still aren't where they're supposed
to be so let's see
like solve the playstation couldn't
effectively change your gamertag for
years and then when they did do it it
said
change at your own
that's your own risk
it may break all your trophies
your trophies are a wrap you know
no it is interesting okay i guess so
that's it that's it no i just said it is
interesting to me that
microsoft is the software company right
and that from a hardware perspective
they seem to be
very forward-facing in terms of tech and
features and things and and the things
to be honest we thought were just
buzzwords and you know i'm like okay let
me see you know say so yeah i got to
give him credit a lot of their what kind
of what shaw caprice said it says that
a lot of the stuff that they've
implemented in my opinion has
transitioned smoother right it's just
more of a it's it just works you know
what i'm saying and you just
do this again it feels like
microsoft because you know the xbox one
generation didn't do the greatest it
feels like they spent a lot of that time
just thinking yeah yeah like how is this
gonna work how's that gonna work and it
seems like playstation was so high on
their own success that they turned
around like yo
the playstation comes out next year what
are we gonna do
you're ridiculous
[Music]
no i said i think more of the fact that
this speaks to
microsoft's focus on keeping everything
yes
basically
like
same as always yeah uniform in fact they
didn't the same the fact that they
didn't have to work on a new design for
a controller the fact that they did have
to work on all of these different things
to basically make the system stand out
completely different from the other
systems and stuff yeah that that ease
into your development that ease it to
your r d and stuff like that so they can
focus on features to make sure that the
box is basically exactly what it needs
to be by adding those little things and
not worrying about the little features
that most people don't even really think
about anymore like think about like how
much like i re i still see quick resume
happen but the fact that they talked
about it a lot like it was a huge
feature it's definitely a great feature
to hack it that helps you get into your
game faster but how much do we actually
look at me like oh i actually just got
into my game fight because you're kind
of used to it now right compared to like
all these features that the playstation
that's finally getting it's like well
this is old now you know unless you were
a person that was on another play like
pc and stuff where you saw this stuff
all the time right on the console frank
you're like this is like a year and a
half too late right you know i'm already
and that's the biggest thing because
playstation put more emphasis on
upgrading the technology of their system
which is not a bad thing it's it's a
great thing
but it also makes it seem like you
probably should have pushed stuff down
the road a little further to make sure
that stuff was all ready to go at one
time versus when it was i mean
in a lot of ways forte when playstation
relaunched the ps5 thing like they they
didn't even have parties function the
same way right right it's just like they
take a step back when it comes to
software but where they should shine i
feel like they're that's what i thought
that's my surprise i'm surprised that
from a hardware standpoint and as i said
i got to give testament you know shout
out to jay serrano and in the team and
in the hallway guys because xbox is
beautiful
like that's the surprise to me because
again
for me as a person of course i like the
ecosystem i like the ecosystem of the
xbox so as a techie it excites me when
the new tech is going to be packaged in
on a ui on a sound or the visual
fidelity and looks like okay we can test
these out and it's it is for the most
part functional i get salt's point with
yeah implementation and perfect
implementation on is it going to be
actually optimized and utilized for
everything but i feel like the ease of
use to get in the door the actual turn
on works not too many problems i have to
say from a console standpoint
they're definitely lapping them there
like it and i do experience already
learned that yeah i feel like on xbox
one they launched without party support
as well they're like never again never
again like they learned from the xbox
one
snafu like they're not doing that
anymore and there is a benefit i
remember the talk in the beginning was
oh it's more of the same and sony's
innovating as far as ui stuff but then
there's the functionality aspect right
when you keep uniformity when you keep
uniformity and then things just work
because it's there back compat you know
all these other things so to me
i like the stability of that and i like
the ease of use of that i like that it
works and that i've i have to admit like
from a technology standpoint it just
seems like yo okay dude boom we're ready
okay this okay we're ready okay quick
resume okay smart delivery it's not just
a buzzword okay no it actually works and
it's ready right that's the thing i just
think they're they're doing a good job
you know from from a generational
standpoint from a hardware standpoint
you got to give credit to the team again
no disrespect
to sony adding a feature that is needed
but it's just one of those things where
you like damn it always feels like
there's a little caveat there's like a
little or maybe if it's you know turn
this on and there might be variability
here then turn it off like it just feels
that way i'll just tell you what the
perception is when it comes to their
hardware feature implementation but
absolute to them vrr is a real thing
frame pacing is a real thing and if you
have it you have a tv to support it it's
a difference so salute to them to to
have to join them so that's what i got
anybody else on the uh vr oh we are done
with that
guess we're done with that so um let's
get these super chats and get one out of
here if you want me to get the poll
while you queue them up but yeah i just
have there's like three
we got bruno
once again with the 28 rayon super chat
you don't need hdmi 2.1 for vrr on xbox
series or xbox one x you can get it on
hdmi 2.0 so my wac tv supports it on my
one thanks but not my ps5
oh amazing yeah
that's messy right there yeah there we
have it pixel bit g remember for 29
months thank you sir
reminder that xbox one s and x had vr
are in hardware last gen great show as
always lords yes sir no doubt
thank you thank you then we have
the last one
wiktor philak
[Music]
my first donation to the lords love you
all this is the best xbox not xbox
podcast
yeah they're so messy salute
and that's it all right let's get this
poll rocking new iop poll which source
is hinting at a required two hour game
trial by developers for the playstation
plus premium service do you feel this is
a pro consumer move by sony the choices
are a yes the ability to try a demo for
every game is just an additional feature
to a service providing backup cloud
streaming and game discount value
choice b why anybody eyes roll no
pay
this is a form of leading the witness
i'm just saying this absolutely this is
the talk
this is the talk on twitter
no
paywalling game demos and making
mandatory requirements of devs is not a
good look when game pass exists or c i
don't care i'm still trying to stack my
playstation plus subscription vouchers
before the spartacus feds get me in june
you're gonna stack those for no reason
because they ain't going to let you
redeem them
oh oh shout out to the best dating
website they out here get them get them
guys get them rich guys they try to sell
that
they're in here they they pushing their
own powder over there
make sure lydia master is good make sure
we get him by a mistake we snipe up by
mistake you know what i'm saying oh my
god i got you got him i'm hot yeah i got
him all right cool just on high lydian
because we ain't gonna get him dude
dirty i think we got him he was a
casualty award he's a casual wolf he was
too he was the too close to the aoe
he's got a blast radius
but look salute to everybody pulled up
of course the legendary sean capri
my man it has been a minute to have you
in the room we are the gamer cast the
xbox drive got to eat with this brother
nyc pulled up did a comic store tour as
well
yeah man salute to you brother so where
can i find people finding what you got
going on sir yeah man it's part of my
bio you can find it
at sean capri sean like connery capri
like the pants it says has men lord
cognition and we had
we had breakfast that's that's right in
there it's like i told my mom about it
dude uh
i love hanging out with you guys this is
absolutely the best i i feel very
fortunate and blessed to be uh to be
asked to join you guys i'm a huge fan
long time listener um and yeah just
celebrating video games it does get
messy at times but
what else where else would we do without
this man
appreciate you brother and you don't get
enough your flowers also for what you do
for charity i want you to talk about
that you don't you know you know talk
about the the things you're involved
with you know for gamers in the
community as well sure man yeah um it's
funny extra life is um somebody was
saying something to do it for the kids
yeah that's that's usually my pitch for
actually like what are you gonna not
donate like what do you want these kids
to die or something like donate to
extradashlife.org man come on
um but we've been doing something really
cool with uh with a team up in rome new
york actually when i saw you last i was
in new york and then i hopped on the
train and uh spent the weekend in rome
new york for extra life phoenix
overdrive is the team and we do it in
person man we are we all get together we
fill a space with like 50 or 60 of us
we've all got tvs to play on and we
stream we raise a bunch of money and i'm
all about setting records for this kind
of stuff we have one good year the next
year is going to be even better the next
year's going to be even better than that
and um now with maybe the world coming
back to normal knock on wood
this year is looking like it's going to
be the biggest one ever and i'm really
excited about it so if anybody wants to
learn about that they can follow on
twitter phoenix overdrive is the team
you can join it extra dash life.org
whether you join us in person or not
like it's just great to be part of a
team that does 10 15 20 000 raising
money for kids and um yeah it's a it's a
good time it just
kind of just adds another angle of how
great this industry really is because
together we raise millions and millions
of dollars at extra life every single
year so it's gotten to the point where i
don't even like really ask my wife if i
can go it's like it's just it's just
happening this i'm gonna be in rome
every year seeing friends it's a good
excuse to to go meet in person the
people who we typically just
coordinate and collaborate with online
so got breakfast in times square
whatever we're going to do
we already know that absolutely thank
you
gotta love it i see uh project x talking
to building join the team we're going
smashing phoenix you know what i'm
saying we got the website in there go
check it out for a good cause really
doing good things and that's legit we
have we begging for likes for the kids
but that's legit for the kids
so go support some real stuff for the
kids no doubt so thank you of course the
legendary
gaming forte feels like it's been a
minute since you've been back in the
round crispy camera dps podcast scumcast
raided with him last night
we got to get back in there today you
know what i'm saying but uh tell the
people what's going on with you man
nah man uh well as soon as i leave here
i'm heading over to fonzes oh that's
right you got double duty that's right
that double duty at least fox is only an
hour so that's good what you're trying
to
say
but um nah man um
great show as always listen to you guys
at work and um nice just finally meet
you sean um
amazing stuff that you do um for extra
life and everything
and uh man it's just crazy to think that
2022 is halfway over lords are still
going strong
halfway to 20k you know
just i'm just happy with the stuff that
you guys do on this channel man and
shout out to you son you have been
missed super chats have not yes yes
you've been gone
they have not been the same but uh for
myself it's a gaming forte everywhere
youtube twitter that's my slide
playstation dps podcast with my co-host
homie best friend slumber backslap we do
it every thursday nine p.m um est it was
on my channel this week it's on his
channel next week so definitely come
through check us out had a really really
good uh conversation with um my former
retail rep from sony
um kronos had some really hot things to
say for sony
i told him i told him i said you can't
hold back bro
so you can put it all out there but um
yeah so make sure you check that
information out and um definitely have a
great weekend enjoy the engagement
playing and um we'll see you guys next
time
i'm trying to get slow to do that i told
him he has to uh platinum it if somebody
does no platinum's on xbox though
oh you're right you're right that's
right we started that game in school
that's right
you know what i can do i can play it in
the cloud straight up here we go
i already know where this is going quick
and easy just slide in like
this
salute the fourth taste of the dps i'll
put the channels in the in the
description go subscribe man go to him
and sean capri put the twitch channel in
there yo go support you guys good
content creators knowledgeable know what
they talk about shout out to fun
speculation he said 14's a real one he's
just a little too obsessed with the
switch because
listen man
he always sits at the desk
dude my dog is named after yoshi
my favorite color one of my favorite
colors is green so
listen this is the only nintendo
character that i truly care about you
know
show all the rest of them
[Laughter]
moving on time
he's messy today he is super
to get back shout out to fun speculation
and of course lord addict in the
building where can you find people find
you what you got going on sir
first off i want to thank our guests for
coming on it was a pleasure having you
on the show uh you can find me on
twitter at lord addict ilp keep in mind
i will be
uh once again we will be doing uh the
attic show this wednesday with uh king
david and uh hip hop gamer
so we're going to see how that's going
to go i'm sure that's going to be
interesting yes um like i said we will
be
starting to do the promotions for like
the prediction show stuff
the the order will be nintendo
playstation xbox um we kind of have a
good idea who the guests are gonna be
but i will be
asking twitter what they think the guest
should be uh doesn't mean it's gonna be
but you know maybe you put that up
[Laughter]
you put that person on that tweet man
maybe they'll be the reason that they
show up and i appreciate it for coming
through we add up to like i i think 820
people
hit that like button man i don't know
how close we are to to the next hundred
that we at it looks like we need like
like 35 more for 500.
if you hit that like button it's like i
said king david will do cartwheels
but every time you hit the like button
the playstation dude airs goes straight
to mark's ernie you're ridiculous
now we're definitely not going to get
the like button now but um
oh man shout out to this song
returning super chats intact the realm
is happy
the complete mismanagement by myself and
addict for the last two weeks
man they were missing member chats and
stuff
[Music]
it was wrong
i'm going to leave you on the alerts
next week i'm sorry
[Laughter]
so what we got so let's go don't you sir
tell everybody you know what it is just
just waiting to move so i i can stop
living out these boxes um and that's it
uh there'll be very little gameplay
again trying to get through that one
game of mlb the show that i've been
playing for the past two weeks um
are you playing it on twitch sir uh i'm
the thing on switch
and little man little man oh that's
crazy you didn't buy it on the
playstation this year no no no no no
playstation has not gotten my mlb money
for two years thank you
to what sir
so you just wanted to give that money to
nintendo this time huh of course why not
it's a reason man nintendo's everybody's
favorite second console there you go
there you go shout out to everybody
[Laughter]
[Music]
out to son capri
of course forte the brothers were coming
through it's like i said that forte i
don't get i i don't get enough time to
podcast with you ever i i know i owe you
guys a podcast
podcast
and of course i got a chance to sit down
with sean and talk and that that's
always a great conversation so that's
amazing stuff so yeah we don't give a
short enough credit for we the gamer
cass no we're the gamers it is really a
unique sit down it's like it's a family
talk on some real life
yeah like you got to promote that more
brother like i really enjoy that show
like for real salute thanks guys i
appreciate that yeah um real just sweet
hangs with strangers from the internet
and then i meet you guys like that's
really where all this started was just
let's just sit down and have a chat
totally different video game podcast
um but yeah it's it's been it's been
great to have you guys on i gotta get
the rest of the panel out too okay one
of these days we'll work out time no
i'm just a dummy with time zones
no it's got together no every time we're
supposed to schedule it or we're trying
to make something a little something
happens
oh man the story's gonna come out i
already know
[Laughter]
but anyway could continue to solve
yourself yeah that's it i'm good lord
king back in the realm freshwater for
packs of fun show productive and now we
back in the realm we're gonna find
people find you in a combat talk last
night
first and foremost i want to say uh
thank you to our esteemed guests that
pulled up
uh it's always dope to hang out with
friends sean capri yo you came through i
was like i just had to zoom in looking
in your background i'm like i'm nosy i'm
a nosy dude come on
i love that i love this
set the series x it's the jenga set yes
it looks like it's
crazy it's jenga you open it up it's
jenga blocks
so somebody come in and try to rob the
day i got serious oh man
wooden blocks
aka the love of yoshi
hey listen man the only person that i
love more than yoshi only person that
loves close to yo she's the family of
you king yeah oh man
we got to play some destiny i apologize
yeah i know traders
got myself i'm offline i'm hiding from
y'all popping on i'll be right there
i'll be right there too
just right he'll just randomly send me
an invite and i'm like oh this is elder
ring i know yes of course you know what
it is i get in here um
this dude's bothering me i told my
brothers keep coming you're going to get
hit
yeah you you remember when the first
time you got yoshi and what was it is it
super mario
world yep nintendo classic and the the
super nes and it had the echoes when you
went down in the tube and you you it was
in the cave and you heard the echoes
that's when i knew that nintendo was on
something different and they introduced
us to a wonderful creature so it's dope
that you got that i got a mario running
around this house someplace he's
possessed
i have him in the 20-inch version
upstairs in my bedroom
[Laughter]
crazy
you keep talking about the yoshi i think
you like this dude i just want to do my
outro and get out of here
i just like the distance he kept from
his bike though that was hilarious he's
like hey he's like
just saying that's kind of crazy like i
gotta step away
yeah on twitter next week we got another
good fight yeah coming up so it would be
the next oh nice combat
and i'll probably have to have every
saturday combat talk with the kings
if if it's gonna be mma if it's gonna be
boxing it's gonna be you and and the
drinks out here you saw the um tequila
that was popping off yes that tequila
went off yo look that up
check that out it's it's smooth got a
nice little thing
i'm not promoting anybody that's not
giving me a bag i'll respect that so you
want me to give you a little bit of
promotion
somebody might buy if you
give me a little
send it my way no doubt
anyway that's what i got good day in the
realm good to be back good to be back
you know what i'm saying pax was fun but
it's good to be doing what we do salute
to shawn caprice with the game before
take so to the chat everybody in there
rocking next month's gonna be an
advantage yeah next month we got stuff
cooking me and attic in the lab man
y'all you're not ready you're not ready
lords are back we're gonna be hitting
this thing hard but um and again salute
to the big cass 200 super forte go
support up he's going to be on um what
you call it uh my boy fonzarelli games
talk live support him shout out to the
um our clan members sending me xbox
that's just live while i'm online talk
about they still talking when they're
gonna raid we're not doing that wait
till we finish anyway that's all i got
anything else anybody else look yeah i
got a couple little things came through
yes please um
uh suicide kings member for 18 months
just spoke to tcl they would like to get
you guys together for a huge sponsorship
king wants that bag but you gotta lose
one guy
[Laughter]
[Music]
for the
tsltc what are we doing
you got you got to capitulate you got to
congratulate you listen you got to go
get your vrr
you got to be complicit with this
anyway
then we got a special message from
aurawolf 2256. love you addy
iop after dark oh
that's so cute
so who's your who's your who's your
who's your interest of saul oh my
interest
play with your joystick was here
[Laughter]
he says
you're my smelly wrestling geek salute
all right let's go
crazy
we got to see y'all we are we're done
we're good oh we finished all we've done
no doubt everybody enjoy your city it's
wrapping up me it's good to be back i
get this chinese food
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh